GOOD MORNING EVERYONE --
WILL -- TAKE THE ROLL CALL
PORTANTINO HERE PORTANTINO
HERE BATES BATES HERE BRADFORD
DORADO HELL HELL HERE
JONES Y. CASKEY I CASKEY
HERE WE HAVE A QUORUM
WE THOUGHT ABOUT --
JUST NOT HAVING A HEARING
TODAY BECAUSE A VACATION PUSH
IT BACK AND OTHER WEEK BY THE
I FIGURED YOU KNOW THERE WERE
SOME MERIT TO THAT SUGGESTION
BUT -- BUT HERE WE ARE WE HAVE
TWO HUNDRED FORTY THREE BILLS
TO HEAR TODAY SEVEN OF WHICH
ARE ELIGIBLE FOR A TO PASS
A MOTION THE REMAINING BILLS
ARE ALL SUSPENSE CANDIDATES
-- THERE ARE FIFTEEN BILLS ON
FILE THAT WILL BE NOT BE HEARD
TODAY SEVEN OF THESE WILL BE
HEARD A LATER DATE AND EIGHT
OTHERS WERE APPROVED AS TWENTY
EIGHT POINT EIGHT SOME AGO
DIRECTLY THE SENATE FOR THE
SERGEANTS HAVE A LIST OF THOSE
ITEMS IF ANYBODY'S INTERESTED AS
REMINDER I'D LIKE TO REITERATE
OUR WE GET TO RATE THAT OUR
MESSAGE TO BOTH -- FOLKS WHO
ARE GOING TO SPEAK AND --
MEMBERS WHO ARE GOING TO SPEAK
THAT TESTIMONY SHOULD BE LIMITED
TO THE PHYSICAL ASPECTS OF THE
BILL PLEASE REFRAIN HIGH SAY
THIS EVERY TIME AND HALF OF YOU
LISTEN AND A HALF OF YOU DON'T
LISTEN BUT I DON'T TAKE I DO
TAKE THEM -- PLEASE
REFRAIN FROM LENGTHY POLICY
DISCUSSIONS BECAUSE YOU ALREADY
HAD YOUR POLICY COMMITTEE THIS
IS ABOUT FISCAL IMPACTS AND
-- WE WILL WE HAVE
A QUORUM SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO
PROCEED -- AND WE HAVE AUTHORS
-- PRESENTING BILLS TO PASS
STONE EGGMAN LACKEY BAUER
CANTON AND SUSPENSE BILLS
-- I THINK EVERYONE ELSE'S WAVE
SO SIXERS MORE MY NOTES
ALL RIGHT SO -- IS FIRST
WHO GOT HERE FIRST MISTER
STONE GOT HERE FIRST
BY COME ON UP
YOU MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THIS BILL DOES CREATES ATTENTION
S. CRAB COMMISSION LIKE SPINY
LOBSTER COMMISSION AND THE
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO ZERO
TWO COMMISSION A. B. FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO IN ORDER FOR
A AN ICONIC INDUSTRY TO
BE ABLE TO DISCUSS IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE AND
OTHER THINGS SO LAST YEAR
I HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
MR MEMBERS BOATBUILDER ON
BEHALF OF THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL THANK YOU SO ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTY TWO ANY OPPOSITION
ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE OTHER
FOR VACATION ALL THE SS
ALL THE FEES OR COSTS ARE
COVERED BY ASSESSMENTS ON THE
THE GRABBERS THAT'S CORRECT
GOOD MORNING MR KERRY MEMBERS
JOLIE UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE -- WE ARE NEUTRAL ON
THIS MEASURE -- BUT WOULD KNOW
THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE ALREADY PARTICIPATES
IN THE JUDGE'S CRAP TASK
FORCE WHICH OPERATES UNDER THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCIES OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL AND SO IF
THIS BILL IS ENACTED -- WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE DEPARTMENT'S ROLE
WOULD NEED TO BE RESTRICTED
A TO PROVIDING PERMIT HOLDER
INFORMATION NECESSARY TO
ESTABLISH AND OPERATE THE
COMMISSION TO KEEP THE COSTS
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE THANK YOU
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
WE HAVE A MOTION WHICH LIKE THE
CLOTHES WELL I WILL NOTE THAT
THE TASK FORCE IS TEMPORARY
BY ITS NATURE THIS WOULD BE
AN ON GOING COMMISSION ASK FOR
EITHER GREAT -- WE HAVE A MOTION
WITHOUT WILL CALL THE ROLL THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE
FLOOR PORTANTINO HI PORTANTINO
I'D BATES BATES AYE BRADFORD
VERIZON DORADO AYE HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES I WE CASKEY
HI MY CASKEY AYE THANK YOU
SAID THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU
WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL WE HAVE
FOUR MISSING ONE PERSON RIGHT
A SURVEY FOR MR JONES IS
HERE SO THAT BILLS ON CALL
ALRIGHT WE'LL GO TO OUR
NEXT AUTHOR PLEASE COME ON A
WITH AGE SIX THERE WE ARE
PLEASE TELL US ABOUT AB THIRTEEN
OH NINE THANK YOU MISTER TURN
MEMBERS WELCOME BACK GLAD TO BE
WITH YOU THIS MORNING I'M HERE
TO PRESENT ON AB THIRTEEN OH
NINE WHICH PRESERVES THE NINETY
DAY ENROLLMENT FOR HEALTHCARE
IT WILL SHIFTED FROM JANUARY
FIFTEENTH TO JANUARY THIRTY
FIRST WHEN I GOT SHIFTED BACK
TO JANUARY FIFTEENTH WE SAW
A DROP OF TWENTY FOUR PERCENT
ENROLLMENT WHICH IS WHY WE
BROUGHT THIS BILL IT HAS A VERY
SMALL FISCAL IMPACT LESS THAN A
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR
-- ACCORDING TO THE ANALYSIS
AND I WILL TURN IT OVER TO
MY WITNESS GOOD MORNING AND JDS
HERE ON BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA THE SPONSORS OF AB
THIRTEEN OH NINE THIS YEAR THE
GOVERNOR AND YOUR LEGISLATURE
JUST REQUIRED CALIFORNIANS
TO BUY HEALTH CARE OR FACE A
PENALTY SB THIRTY NINE ALLOWS
THEM A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME WITH
THE NEW YEAR BEGINS IN ORDER
FOR THEM TO EDUCATE THEMSELVES
ABOUT COVERAGE THE COMEDIAN
HOUSES NOW IT'S VERY MINIMAL
AND OBSERVABLE COSTS TO THE MHC
IN ORDER TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL
-- FOR THESE REASON BE REQUESTS
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
EIGHT BORDERS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF HEALTH UNDERWRITERS AND
SUPPORT SURE ANY OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE IS THERE FOR HELP
YES THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES COSTS
OF FORTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS
MANAGED CARE FUN IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY ONE HUNDRED
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FORTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER A BOTH COVERED
CALIFORNIA AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF INSURANCE REPORT NO FISCAL
IMPACT RESULTING FROM THIS
BILL THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS
WE HAVE A MOTION SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE THE SPECS LAST YEAR
I'VE A FAVOR CLOSE ALL RIGHT
WITH TAKE A VOTE THE MOTION
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
AYE PORTANTINO AYE BATES
BRADFORD THE RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE
JONES JONES I Y. CASKEY
MY BECAUSE HE AYE
BATES I WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT WHO'S NEXT
THIS IS THE QUIRK
HE DID WHERE'S
BURKE CHAU LOWERS
THERE YOU ARE FIFTY AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN YES -- GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND SENATORS AB THIRTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN REQUIRES DTS SHE
TO HOLD AT LEAST FOR PUBLIC
MEETINGS EACH YEAR AND AT
THOSE MEETINGS TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE ON PERMITTING ARE
CLEAN UP SITES IN FORSMAN AND
REGULATORY ACTIVITY OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS HAS BEEN
NUMEROUS LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT
HEARINGS ON THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL ONE OF
THE MOST CONSISTENT CRITICISMS
HAS BEEN A LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
IN THIS TO DECISION MAKING AB
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND ENSURES
THAT THE DEPARTMENT DECISIONS
ARE MADE IN A MORE TRANSPARENT
WAY IN THE PUBLIC IS MORE
INVOLVED IN THEIR APARTMENTS
PROGRAMS AND PROCESSES --
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SIR
FOR HELP YES THE DEPARTMENT
OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL
ESTIMATES A EACH PUBLIC MEETING
WOULD COST APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS TOTALING
ONE HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN VERY SPECIAL FUNDS
FOR FISCAL YEAR OF WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT IMPOSES ADDITIONAL COSTS
ON BOTH THE HAZARDOUS WASTE
CONTROL ACCOUNT AND THE TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL ACCOUNT WHICH
WOULD EXACERBATE THE STRUCTURAL
IMBALANCE IN EACH OF THE SUN
ANY QUESTIONS FIRST WORK
OUR MOTION WE WILL WE HAVE
A MOTION MISSED QUIRK WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
WE LIKE THAT ALL RIGHT WILL TAKE
A VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES
AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D RAZA
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES I WIECKOWSKI MY COUNTY I
THANK YOU AGAIN THE BILL
IS OUT SEVEN TWO ZERO I SEE
MISS EGGMAN IN THE ROOM YOU
HAVE THREE BILLS TO PERCENT
PLEASE START WITH A. B. FOURTEEN
NINETEEN ALL RIGHT GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY BECAUSE WE WELCOME
EACH OTHER BACK BEFORE NINETEEN
IS THE AGRICULTURAL COMMITTEE
OMNIBUS BILL TO EXTEND THE
SUNSET FOR SEVERAL PROGRAMS
WITH THE FOOD IN AG DEPARTMENT
THE BILL WILL EXTEND TILL
JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
SUNSET FOR FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
STANDARDIZATION EXTEND TO TWENTY
TWENTY SIX THE FDA'S PROGRAM TO
LICENSE AND FORCE ISSUES RELATED
TO IT IN EDIBLE KITCHEN GREASE
ENFORCEMENT AND EXTENDS TO JULY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TO SUNSET
OPTIONAL COUNTY SUBVENTION
PROGRAM FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
ACTIVITIES AND OTHER PROVISIONS
OF THE CALIFORNIA SEED LÀ I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
ABOUT THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE WOULDN'T
DRAW ON THIS MEASURE ANY
QUESTIONS I HAVE A MOTION
SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
TO SIXTY THREE I WROTE ALL
RIGHT WITH THAT WILL TAKE THE
VOTE THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I DRAW SOON
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES I WE CASKEY I CASKEY AYE
WAS OUT WILL GO ON SEVEN
ZERO WILL GO ON TO AB SIX
FIVE SEVEN THIS
BILL EXTENDS A SUNSET DATE FOR
COMMERCIAL FEED TO LICENSURE
AND INSPECTION TONNAGE TAX FROM
JANUARY ONE TO TWENTY TWENTY
TWO JANUARY ONE TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE THE BILL ALSO INCREASES
THE MAXIMUM RATE OF THE TONNAGE
FROM ZERO FROM FIFTEEN CENTS
TO TWENTY FIVE PER TON OF
COMMERCIAL FEED SOUL IN THE
FUNDING IS USED FOR EDUCATION
AND RESEARCH REGARDING THE
SAFE HANDLING OF COMMERCIAL
FOOD OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WE HAVE ONE OR MEMBERS AND
THREE MILLION ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA GREEN FEES
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT THANK
YOU WHAT'S YOUR NAME AGAIN
I JUST CHECKING ALL RIGHT
IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
IS THERE FILE YES WERE NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE AS IT --
EXTENDS CURRENT SUNSETS AND
PROVIDE CDFA WITH ADDITIONAL
FLEXIBILITY TO IMPLEMENT
PROGRAMS ARE THERE QUESTIONS
WE HAVE A QUESTION
GOOD MORNING LATE MORNING I JUST
HAVE A QUESTION IT'S KIND OF A
MAJOR INCREASE -- IN ALMOST
ALMOST A HUNDRED PERCENT FIFTEEN
CENTS TWENTY FIVE CENTS A
LITTLE EXPLANATION ON -- WHAT
THE WHAT THE MEDIA'S REALIZING
IT WENT BACK TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY TWO THEY WAITED A LONG
TIME THAT TAUGHT WONDERFULLY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING WHAT'S
THE ADDITIONAL FUNDING NEED
I GUESS IS A BETTER QUESTION
IT IS INDUSTRY SPONSORED AND
THEY DECIDED THIS IS WHERE
THEY NEED TO BE ABLE TO TO HAVE
EIGHT IMPLEMENT THE PROGRAM
-- THE COST FOR EVERYTHING HAS
GONE UP AND THEY THEY WANT TO
MORE FLEXIBILITY FOR THAT CDFA
THANK YOU JENNIFER
GIVEN OUR FEEDSTOCK
SAFE QUESTION
FROM OF
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
HAVE A ALL RIGHT CALDWELL
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES AYE
BRADFORD BRADFORD I DRAW SOON
DORADO AYE HILL HILL AYE JONES
JONES I WHITE HOUSE GAVE MY
CASKEY I WAS OUT SEVEN
ZERO WILL GO ON TO AB EIGHTEEN
NO ONE WHICH IS COMMITTEE BILL
-- DEALING WITH CATTLE THIS
BILL DOES THE FOLLOWING ELEMENTS
REQUIREMENTS CERTAIN CATTLE
NEED PROOF OF VACCINATION AT
THE CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP WITH
IN CALIFORNIA UPDATES THE
CURRENT BRAND FEE STRUCTURE
IN AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FOOD NICK
TO INCREASE THE LIVESTOCK
INSPECTION FEE BY TWENTY
PERCENT WITH THE APPROVAL
OF LIVESTOCK IDENTIFICATION
ADVISORY BOARD AND CHANGE
THE RECENT MOBILE SLAUGHTER
LAW TO APPLY TO CATALONIA
KEEP IN OUR CATTLE SAFER FOOD
STOCKS SAFE IN MAKING SURE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE CONTINUES
TO BE THE LEADER IN THE WORLD
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
RIGHT SIR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
SIR WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IS
THERE FILE GUESTS WERE NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE OR NEUTRAL
ON THE CHEESE BURGERS ARE
RIGHT ANYBODY
HAVE A QUESTION YES MR OZ OF
PLAIN WHITE THE EXEMPTION
FROM THE VACCINATION WHAT
WHAT WHAT IS THAT AS
THE IN THE INDUSTRY FELT LIKE
IT WASN'T DID WAS INAPPROPRIATE
THAT AT THAT TIME TO BE ABLE
TO PROVE IT WHEN SHE WOULD HAVE
PROVIDED THE SHOT IT GENERALLY
DOESN'T GO AWAY AGAIN SO IF
YOU JUST IF YOU THEN HAVE TO
RE SHOW IT JUST LIKE OUR OWN
VACCINATION RECORDS THEY MAY
BE YOU KNOW NOT AS EASY AS
READILY AVAILABLE THIS IS FOR
THE SALE OF A COW AFTER THE
FACT AND THEY'VE THEY'VE BEEN
VACCINATED IN THE BEGINNING
THEY'VE ALREADY BEEN
VACCINATED THEY'VE ALREADY
BEEN VACCINATED SO THIS IS
A CHANGE OF OWNERSHIP THAT YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE TO THEN RE FAX IT
SHOW PROOF OKAY
ALRIGHT WE HAVE A
MOTION WE GET HAVE MOVE
MOVE XIN -- MUHSIN
WE GET A ROOM THE BILL
MISTER BRADFORD DID
YOU MOVE THE BILL HEY
WE HAVE A MOTION ALL RIGHT
WILL CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE BATES
BATES AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
EITHER AWESOME DORADO AYE
HILL HILL AYE JONES JONES
I WAY CASKEY MAKOVSKY I
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE WILL LIFT THE CALL
WE HAVE TWO BILLS ON CALL
RIGHT WE HAVE TWO BILLS
ON CALL RIGHT SO IT'S WITH
THE CALLS ON THOSE BILLS
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY TWO
STONE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE SENATE FLOOR
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
THE BILL IS OUT SEVEN ZERO
AB AB THIRTEEN
OH NINE POWER CON THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR BRADFORD HI
THE BILL WAS OUT SEVEN ZERO
-- WE HAVE ONE LAST TO PASS
MUSTER LACKEY IS ON HIS WAY
-- SO WE'LL GO TO THE TOP OF
OUR AGENDA SB SIX SIX FIVE
BY MR UMBER IS A SUSPENSE
AND IT EIGHT IS THERE ANYONE
HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
SIX FIVE ANYBODY IN OPPOSITION
SIR FILE YES WE DON'T HAVE
AN APPROVED POSITION ON THIS
THAT WOULD NOTE THAT THIS
BILL EXPANDS THE POSSIBLE
USES OF EXISTING MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDS
BY THE COUNTIES AND PROVIDE
THEM WITH GREATER FLEXIBILITY
IN THE USE OF THESE FUNDS
ALL RIGHT -- WITHOUT OBJECTION
A SB SIX SIX FIVE AGO THE
SUSPENSE S. C. EIGHTY
ONE BY MISTER ALLEN -- IS
THEIR SUPPORT FOR SCA ONE
MR TURN MEMBERS OBVIOUSLY
SHAUN BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
WERE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS
OF THIS MEASURE AND ALSO LIKE
TO VOICE SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF THE CITIES OF SANTA MONICA
AND BEVERLY HILLS THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY MEASURE
BE HAVE TO THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD ALSO IN SUPPORT
-- OPPOSITION SEEING NONE IS
THERE FILE YES THE SECRETARY
OF STATE ESTIMATES THE COST
PER PAGE PUT THIS ON THE BALLOT
IS SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON THE AVERAGE MEASURE
OF WHICH IS SIX TO TEN PAGES
ACTUAL COST MAY DIFFER DEPENDING
ON THE LENGTH OF THE ACTUAL
ELEMENTS IN THIS AND ON THE
SIZE OF THE BALLOT GREAT
SEEING NO QUESTIONS ARE COMMON
WITHOUT OBJECTION SCA ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
SANTIAGO A. B. TO CALIFORNIA
COLLEGE PROMISES THEIR SUPPORT
MOREOVER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT TO OPPOSITION
THEIR FILE YES WERE NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
LINES WITH THE INTENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE PROMISE
PROGRAM -- BY CLARIFYING THE
SPECIFIED STUDENTS WHO ARE
CLASSIFIED AS FULL TIME STUDENT
SHOULD BE ELIGIBLE HOWEVER --
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THE BILL
SHOULD BE STRUCTURED TO COMMENCE
WITH THE TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE FISCAL YEAR TO ENABLE THE
ADMINISTRATION AND LEGISLATURE
TO CONSIDER THE BUDGETARY COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH EXPANDING THE
NUMBER OF ELIGIBLE STUDENTS
SEEING NO HANDS GO UP WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB FORTINO SEVEN
SHOULD BE FOUR OH SEVEN
THANK YOU THE SAME THING
TWICE AB FOUR OH SEVEN MR
SANTIAGO IS THEIR SUPPORT
SEC MOVING OVER TOWARD
THE MICROPHONE TOLERANCE
THIS ONE IS WONDER CM NEUTRAL ON
THE BILL -- I BELIEVE THE INTENT
OF BILLS TO MAKE OBTAINING A
FEROCITY SUPERVISOR OPERATOR
PERMIT EASIER FOR DOCTORS
THERE'S A CONTRADICTION IN A
BILL THAT WILL ALLOW DOCTORS
TO OBTAIN ONE PERMIT TO DO THE
JOB OF TO PERMITS IN THE STATUS
FOR PERMITS THAT DOCTORS CAN
GET FOR FOR SPECIFIC MODALITIES
IF THIS PASSES AS IT IS IT WILL
REDUCE REVENUE TO THE STATE
BECAUSE BOXING GET ONE PERMIT
TO DO THE JOB OF TO FURTHER
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL IS
OBVIOUSLY TO BYPASS THIS LOOK
CROSSING BRANCH OF THE STATE --
THE SLOW CROSSING BRANCHES
COSTING TAXPAYERS A LOT OF MONEY
AND IT'S PROCESSING EVERYTHING
VIA MAIL ONLY SO FEELS LIKE
THIS BILL IS BY PASSING THE
REAL ISSUE WHICH IS A SLOW
PROCESS BRANCHES THE NEXT
THANK YOU OTHERS OPPOSITION
THIS FEATURE IN MEMBERS BOB
ACT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
RHEOLOGICAL SOCIETY OPPOSE ON
POLICY GROUNDS BUT THE ANALYSIS
DOES POINT OUT THE CHANGE IN
THIS RECOVERY REQUIREMENTS
HERE THE DEPARTMENT TO
ASSESS THE COMPETENCY RATHER
USE A STANDARDIZED TESTING
METHODOLOGIES SO WHERE POST THE
BILL THANK YOU SEEN NO OTHER
RUSSIA THE MICROPHONE IS OUR
FILE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
COSTS TO THE RADIATION CONTROL
FUN NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES ONGOING
COST OF ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THE FUND A
TO DEVELOP REGULATIONS PREPARE
RULE MAKING DOCUMENTATION ISSUE
PUBLIC NOTICES AND CONDUCT
PUBLIC HEARINGS ADDITIONALLY
THE DEPARTMENT REPORTS UNKNOWN
COSTS IN BROOKLYN INCREASES TO
PROCESS NEW APPLICATIONS OF X.
RAYS SUPERVISOR AND OPERATORS
PERMITS SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FORTINO SEVEN WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE FOUR SEVEN I KEEP
ADDING AN EXTRA DIGIT -- AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY FIVE COURT
REPORTERS HIS THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE YES WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THE RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES
-- A BY INCREASING COURT COSTS
TO OBTAIN TRANSCRIPTS ACCORDING
TO THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL THIS
BILL WOULD INCREASE STATEWIDE
COURT COSTS BY APPROXIMATELY
SEVEN POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY -- ADDITIONALLY --
THIS BILLS FEE INCREASES WOULD
APPLY TO LITIGANTS ATTORNEYS
AND OTHER PARTIES PURCHASING
TRANSCRIPTS SHE NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB FORTINO FOR A NONPROFIT
SPONSORS IS THERE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE ESTIMATES THIS BILL
WILL RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY TWENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND
FOR NEW PERMANENT POSITIONS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FORTINO FOR WILL
GO THE SUSPENSE AB FIFTEEN SIXTY
THREE SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
SHARE FILE YES WE ARE NEUTRAL ON
THIS MEASURE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COSTS OF FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AN ON
GOING SEEING NO QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTY THREE GOT A
SUSPENSE -- AB FIFTY ONE
DEVELOPERS PAYING ATTENTION
AB FIVE ALL RIGHT
AB FIVE I WAS JUST DOING
NO ONE EVEN FLAME TO ACCEPT YOU
AND ME DAY HE DID ALL
RIGHT AB FIVE THOSE IN SUPPORT
PLEASE LINE UP NOW REMEMBER
THIS IS A FISCAL COMMITTEE
ALL RIGHTS GO GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS BRIAN SHAPE AND
I'M WITH THE AMERICAN SOCIETY
OF TRAVEL ADVISORS AND THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF TRAVEL
ORGANIZATIONS IS CONFIRMED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
THE DYNAMICS ISSUE HAS FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS ON THE STATE SIXTY
TEO WHEN ASKED TO BOTH SUPPORT
EIGHTY FIVE IF THE IF AMENDED
TO INCLUDE THE SELLER OF TRAVEL
PROVISION THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
UNDER CONSIDERATION THANK YOU
MY NAME IS THAT C. GEYSER ON
BUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF TROUBLE ORGANIZATIONS IN
THE AMERICAN SOCIETY OF TRAVEL
ADVISORS AS CONFIRMED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS THE NIGHT MAX
ISSUE HAS FISCAL IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE STATE CC TEO AND
ASKED THE SUPPORT AB FIGHT IF IT
IS AMENDED TO INCLUDE THE SELLER
OF TROUBLE PROVISION THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS UNDER CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU HELLO MY
NAME IS A NEED A POLY ALSO I'M
THE OWNER OF TICKET TO TRAVEL IN
SAN AS A SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
TWO AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
TRAVEL HOSE AND ALSO A BOARD
MEMBER OF C. CTO THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION COALITION OF TRAVEL
ORGANIZATION AND THEN I TO I'M
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL BECAUSE
IT IS CONFIRMED IN THE ANALYSIS
THE DYNAMICS ISSUE HAS FISCAL
IMPLICATIONS TO THE STATE AND
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
TRAVEL ORGANIZATION AT ASSEN
AMERICAN SOCIETY OF TRAVEL
AGENTS OR SUPPORT AB FIVE IT
IS AMENDED TO INCLUDE THE SALAR
TRAVELED PROVISIONS THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS UNDER CONSIDERATION
THANK YOU ARE WHO ELSE IS FROM
TRAVEL ALL THE TRAVEL FOLKS
RAISE YOUR HAND AND IF YOU
GET ALL SO YOU'RE NOT WOULD
TRAVEL ARE YOU GOING NEXT IN
A GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS CREAM GREASY ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT ALL RIGHT
NOW IF YOU COULD JUST SAY I
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
THE PRIOR TRAVEL SPEAKER THAT
WOULD SAVE US TIME IN TRADITION
NAME EVIL STEVE OR TRUMP
PLAZA TRAVELING LOS ANGELES
I AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS OF
THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS AND IS A
HALF A BILLION DOLLAR FINANCIAL
INDUSTRY ARE ALMOST THERE NEXT
PERSON JUST SAY YOUR NAME AND
I ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
THE PRIOR TRAVEL YOU COULD
EVEN SAY STRONGLY ASSOCIATED
MY NAME IS PAM MILTON I'VE
AN INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
FOR FROSH HAVE BEEN FOR TEN
YEARS AND I I AGREE I WANT THE
EXEMPTION THANK YOU OF THAT
MARY RYAN PLAID END IN THE
PENDING CONTRACTOR AND I
STRONGLY AGREE WITH THE
PREVIOUS COMMENTS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
I'M JOHN PLUG AND I STRONGLY
AGREE WITH EVERYBODY ELSE
THANK ALL RIGHT SMART MAN
KATHY SCHULZ INDEPENDENT
CONTRACTOR AND I STRONGLY
AGREE WITH EVERYONE ALL RIGHT
PAGE HERE ANY GALLAGHER OUR
TRAVEL PROFESSIONAL AND I AGREE
WITH EVERYONE ELSE THANK YOU
HE WILL WORK SHOT TRAVEL
PROFESSIONAL AND I'M IN
AGREEMENT WITH THE OTHER TRAVEL
THANK YOU MATTHEW WALDRON
I'M A TRAVEL ADVISORY
BOARD MEMBER OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRAVEL ASSOCIATION
FOR TRAVEL ADVISORS AND I
AGREE WITH PREVIOUS COMIC
I NEED A BANDAGE AND AN EMPLOYEE
WITH TRAVEL STORE AND I STRONGLY
AGREE WITH THE OTHERS THANK YOU
THIRTY FLORES WITH TRAVEL
STORE AND CAL TRAVEL STORE
AND I STRONGLY AGREE WITH
ALL THE OTHER COMMENTS ABOUT
THE EXEMPTION THANK YOU
MY NAME IS MICHELLE STEVENS
I'M A PROFESSIONAL CONFERENCE
INTERPRETER I BRING A PETITION
BEARING THE SIGNATURES OF
TWO THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
INTERPRETERS WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE WITH AN EXEMPTION FOR
INTERPRETERS AND TRANSLATORS WE
ARE NOT THE GIG ECONOMY WORKERS
AB FIVE IS DESIGNED TO PROTECT
BUT RATHER HIGHLY TRAINED
AND SKILLED PROFESSIONALS
WITH ESTABLISHED PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS TO ADEQUATELY PERFORM
OUR WORK WE HAVE BEEN WORKING AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS IN OUR
INDUSTRY FOR FIFTY PLUS YEARS
THE MAJORITY OF US BELONG TO
THE INTERNATIONAL AND NATIONAL
PROFESSIONAL ASSOCIATIONS
THAT SET SUCH STANDARDS MOST
OF US ARE CERTIFIED BY STATE
AND FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS WE
OPERATE AS TRUE ENTITIES AND OUR
CORPORATIONS LLC'S AND SOLE
PROPRIETOR BUSINESSES WE HAVE
BUSINESS LICENSES AND PROMOTE
OURSELVES PUBLICLY AND WORK IN
A BUSINESS TO BUSINESS CAPACITY
I'M GOING TO LEAVE COPIES OF THE
OPEN LETTER AND THE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED SIGNATURES FOR YOU
THANKS PLEASE GIVE IT TO THE
SERGEANTS AND GOOD MORNING
A HISTORY ONE AT A MOVE OUT OF
THE CAMERA LINER WHEN I KNOW
YOU LIKE TO BE IN THE CAMERA
ALSO PROFESSIONAL CERTIFIED
INTERPRETER ON BEHALF OF A CHECK
THE ASSOCIATION OF INDEPENDENT
ADDITION TO PRESERVE CALIFORNIA
REQUESTING THAT INTERPRETERS
AS PROFESSIONALS BE EXEMPTED
FROM AB FIVE ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER INTERPRETERS ALL RIGHT
YES GOOD MORNING ONE OTHER
INTERPRETER LEFT JUST NOW
THERE'S ONE MORE IN THE BACK SO
JUST SAY ICE PLEASE ASSOCIATE
MY COMMENTS WITH THE PRIOR
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THE
PRIOR AND YOUR NAME MY NAME
IS PATRICIA HYATT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ARE IN ANY OTHER LET
THE OTHER INTERPRETER COME UP
HI BILL GLASSER LANGUAGE
WORLD SERVICES -- I I AM
NOT IN SUPPORT OF CARVE OUTS
FOR -- INTERPRETERS IN THE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AND
SOCIAL SERVICES WORLD -- SO I
WEAR A DIFFERENT SORT OF SUBSET
OF INTERPRETERS AND I BELIEVE
WE SHOULD ALL BE EMPLOYEES
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
SIR ALL RIGHT NEXT INDUSTRY
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS JESSE
RUN A AND I AM HERE WITH THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
AND STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
I AM ALLEYS KIMBO AND I'M THE
OTHER FELLOW TRAVELERS HERE
AND I SUPPORT THE BILL WOULD
BE THE EXCEPTION THANK YOU
IT BORDERS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
HEALTH UNDERWRITERS AND SUPPORT
JOHN NOR WOULD I'M BEHALF OF
THE INDEPENDENT INSURANCE AGENTS
AND BROKERS FOR CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU ALL RIGHT IS
THE WE SURE HAD SOME OPPOSITION
MIXED IN WITH SUPPORT FROM AND
IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
OF AB FIVE ALL
RIGHT SEEING NO MORE COMMENTS
IS THERE FILE YES WE DON'T
HAVE AN APPROVED POSITION
ON THIS BUT WE KNOW THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES COSTS OF
TWO POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
INITIALLY AND TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FROM
THE LABOR STANDARDS ENFORCEMENT
FUND IN THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH FUN TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
ADDITIONALLY THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES
COSTS OF TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO POINT NINE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO FROM THE UNEMPLOYMENT
ADMINISTRATION FUND TO IMPLEMENT
THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER JONES YOU HAVE
A COMMENT OR QUESTION THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST WANTED
TO MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT TO ALL
THE FOLKS WHO CAME TO TESTIFY
THIS MORNING AND -- SOMETIMES IT
CAN BE -- DISAPPOINTING TO COME
TO A COMMITTEE HEARING IN ONLY
BE ABLE TO SHARE YOUR NAME AND
AFFILIATION POSITION BUT PLEASE
UNDERSTAND THAT -- YOUR COMMENTS
THIS MORNING ARE HEARD AND
UNDERSTOOD AND -- WE ALL UP HERE
APPRECIATE THE TIME AND EXPENSE
THAT YOU ALL TOOK OUT OF YOUR
BUSINESSES AND -- YOUR TIME AT
HOME TO BE HERE TODAY TO TESTIFY
ON THIS THIS IS OBVIOUSLY A BIG
BILL -- LOTS OF -- CONCERNS
AND -- THINGS ARE GOING TO
WORK OUT ON IT I I BELIEVE THAT
THIS DYNAMICS DECISION FROM THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT MIGHT
GO DOWN IN HISTORY AS ONE OF
THE WORST DECISIONS THAT COURT
HAS EVER MADE AND --
LAUGHING NO CLASS SO THE
SO PLEASE BE PATIENT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE TRY TO WORK
THIS OUT WE'RE ALL COMMITTED
TO COMING UP WITH THE BEST
PRODUCT AND AB FIVE THAT WE CAN
AND -- SOLVE THE PROBLEMS THAT
THE CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
TREATY FOR SO I JUST WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR COMING TODAY
AND BEING A PART OF THE PROCESS
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT YOU'RE HERE
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS
WHAT TO PLEASE A MAN
OKAY YOUR QUE
ALL RIGHT -- SEE NO FURTHER
COMMENT I'M SORRY I'M SORRY MS
BATES I'M JUST FINE AND NO TO
THE TRAVEL -- ADVISORS SIDE WE
HAD A LARGE CONTINGENT WELCOME
TO OUR DISTRICT OFFICES ALSO SO
YOU HAVE DONE AN EXCELLENT JOB
IN ADVOCATING FOR YOUR POSITION
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT
JUST TO GET TO THAT
THERE YOU GO SEE
TO ALL RIGHT
MISS SEEING NO COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIVE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MR LACKEY
PLEASE COME UP AND TELL US
ABOUT YOUR BILL
YES VERY IMPORTANT SUBJECT
THERE IS AB NINE EIGHT FOUR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
I AM PROUD TO PRESENT AB NINETY
FOUR WHICH CREATES A VOLUNTARY
CONTRIBUTION FUND TO PROVIDE
MORE RESOURCES TOWARD SUICIDE
PREVENTION I'D LIKE TO BEGIN
BY THANKING YOU MISTER CHAIR
FOR YOUR CO AUTHORSHIP AND
COMMITMENT TOWARDS ADDRESSING
THIS VERY SURE IS CRISIS
TO SIDE RICHER ON THE RISE
NATIONALLY IN AND ALSO IN OUR
STATE HERE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NEARLY FOUR THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS
TOOK THEIR OWN LIVES THIS
IS A STAGGERING INCREASE
FROM TWO THOUSAND ONE RATES
FOR APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
THREE PERCENT LOWER MANY OF
THESE ARE YOUNG PEOPLE THAT
SUICIDE IS THE SECOND AND THIRD
LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
CHILDREN AND YOUNG ADULTS MORE
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND CRISIS
INTERVENTION ARE NEEDED FOR AT
RISK POPULATIONS PARTICULARLY
THOSE WHO LIVE IN RURAL
LOCATIONS TWO SIDE IS MOST
PREVALENT IN RURAL AREAS OF
THE STATE WHERE THERE ARE FEWER
CENTERS AND SUPPORT NETWORKS
AB NINE EIGHTY FOUR ADDRESSES
THIS ISSUE BY CREATING A
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTION SO THE
RESOURCES COULD BE GIVEN TO
THOSE WHO ARE MOST VULNERABLE
AGAIN THIS BILL HAS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND AUTHORSHIP AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EVERYONE'S
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL USER ANY
SPEAK ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OPPOSITION IS SERRA FILE
YES -- UNDERSTANDING THE
SENSITIVITY OF THIS ISSUE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE OF THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ESTIMATES
THAT WOULD REDUCE GENERAL FUND
REVENUES BY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR BEGINNING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE -- THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES OVERSIGHT
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMISSION
STATES THAT IT'S COSTS WOULD
BE MINOR AN OBSERVABLE AND
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD STATES
THAT IT WOULD NOT AFFECT ITS
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER LACKEY
SING THE QUESTIONS LIKE TO CLOSE
OR JUST OUT FOR YOUR SUPPORT
AND -- THIS IS A CRISIS THANK
YOU IT IS -- AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I'M HAPPY
TO BE A CO AUTHOR AND STRONGLY
RECOMMENDED TO PASS WITH THAT
WILL TAKE HIM TAKE THE BILL WE
HAVE A MOTION WE'LL TAKE A LOOK
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
SENATE FLOOR PORTANTINO I AM
PORTANTINO AYE BATES BATES
AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD I'D DRAW
SOON TO ROSS SO I HILL HILL
AYE JONES JONES I Y. CASKEY
CASKEY AYE THANK YOU EVERYONE
THANK YOU THE BILL WAS OUT
SEVEN ZERO SO THAT WAS OUR ALL
OF OUR DO PASS RECOMMENDATIONS
I BELIEVE EVERYONE ELSE'S WAVE
PRESENTATION AND SO WE HAVE
OUR SEVERAL PAGES LONG
SUSPENSE FILE LIST WHICH WE
WILL GO BACK TO AB FIFTY ONE
-- IS GONZALEZ ON EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION OTHERS SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY ONE
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
SHARE FILE OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES COST OF FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR AND
FOUR HUNDRED FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE FUND
-- BOTH THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATE
MINOR UNOBSERVABLE COSTS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTY ONE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB ONE SEVEN
ONE IS THERE ANYBODY
IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
SHARE FILE YES WE'RE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AT AS A RESULT
IN INCREASED GENERAL FUND COSTS
A DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THIS BILL
WILL REQUIRE ONE HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING A DUE TO AN INCREASE IN
THE NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
THE BILL WILL EXPAND THE SCOPE
OF EXISTING CRIMES -- AND RESULT
IN AN ADDITIONAL MINOR GENERAL
FUND COSTS SHE NEVER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB ONE SEVENTY ONE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB TWO EIGHTEEN
STATURE LIMITATIONS SIR SUPPORT
COMING UP HERE ALL RIGHT
OPPOSITION SIR SUPPORT
ARE YOU OPPOSITION TO ARE
YOU GUYS BEAT THAT ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT IT'S HARD TO TELL WITH
ALL OF YOU ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
OPPOSITION MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS STATE FOR JUST A
CALIFORNIA ADVOCATES ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF JOINT POWERS AUTHORITIES AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION AB TWO
EIGHTEEN UNLESS IT IS AMENDED
TO INCLUDE STRONG EFFECTIVE
PREVENTION MEASURES TO COMPANY
CONSTRUCTIVE AND FAIR VICTIM
COMPENSATION WE APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR'S INTENT AND ARE FULLY
COMMITTED TO CONTINUALLY
CREATING A SAFE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT FOR ALL CHILDREN WE
WANT TO PROTECT KIDS AND BELIEVE
THAT THERE ARE BETTER WAYS
TO DO THIS AND FUNNELING PROP
NINETY EIGHT DOLLARS INTO CIVIL
LITIGATION THIS BILL FORCES
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN PAYMENTS
FROM TODAY'S SCHOOLS FOR CLAIMS
THAT HAD NO FISCAL RESERVE THAT
WERE INVOLVING EMPLOYEES IN
ADMINISTRATIONS THAT WERE LONG
GONE INCREASES LITIGATION COSTS
AND WITH ATTORNEYS COLLECTING
FORTY TO SIXTY PERCENT OF
SETTLEMENTS AND IT LIMITS NEEDED
ACCESS AND RE INSURANCE OPTIONS
THREE SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASING
RATES HARD CAPS EXCLUSIONS
LIMITS ON COVERAGE AND STRICTER
UNDERWRITING POTENTIALLY LEADING
STUDENTS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WITHOUT COVERAGE AND EXPOSED
TO THE DIRECT COST OF THESE
CLAIMS RISK PULLING JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITIES ARE NOT INSURANCE
BUT THEY SELL FUND TO FILL
IN THE GAPS OF LIABILITY THAT
INSURANCE COMPANIES DON'T COVER
THEIR NONPROFIT PUBLIC ENTITIES
THAT PAY FOR THE COST OF CLAIMS
TO SCHOOL BUDGETS AND TAXPAYER
DOLLARS EACH GPA SERVE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF SCHOOLS AND OTHER
PUBLIC ENTITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT WERE BORN IN THE NINETEEN
SEVENTIES AT A TIME WHEN
INSURANCE COMPANIES REFUSE TO
PROVIDE COMMERCIAL COVERAGE
TO THESE PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
WE ARE HEADED TOWARDS THE C.
M. ENVIRONMENT AND WE BELIEVE
THAT ARE BETTER SOLUTIONS
TO PREVENT THE DIVERSION
OF THESE PROP NINETY EIGHT
DOLLARS AND FOR THOSE REASONS
WERE RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED
LYNNE WELCH ON BEHALF OF THE
SCHOOLS INSURANCE AUTHORITY
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT IT'S IMPORTANT TO
UNDERSTAND OUR STATE'S PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ARE ALREADY AND FISCAL
JEOPARDY EVEN WITHOUT THIS
BILL THEY ARE ALREADY LOSING
INSURANCE COVERAGE BECAUSE
THE LAWSUIT BEING FILED IT'S
NOT A MATTER OF OPPOSING
COMPENSATION FOR VICTIMS TO
MATTER OF MAKING SURE THAT AS
THEY SEEK COMPENSATION THEY'RE
GETTING COMPENSATED FAIRLY
WITHOUT UNNECESSARY COSTS TO
THE STATE AND THE SCHOOLS ARE
DOING SOMETHING TO PREVENT THESE
INCIDENTS FROM HAPPENING THERE
IS NOT A STITCH OF PREVENTION
IN THIS BILL THERE COULD BE
IT'S A MATTER OF SITTING DOWN
AND WORKING OUT A SITUATION
THAT COMPENSATES THE VICTIMS
LOOKS AT THE SITUATION THAT
ALREADY EXISTS IN THE SCHOOLS
AND CREATES A STRUCTURE A MULTI
AGENCY STRUCTURE ACTUALLY IS
WHAT'S NECESSARY TO MAKE SURE
THESE INCIDENTS DON'T HAPPEN
THERE'S AND THERE'S BEEN NO
THINKING ABOUT THAT AS THESE
BILLS HAVE BEEN GOING FORWARD
YEAR AFTER YEAR WE HAVE TO
START THINKING ABOUT ACTUALLY
PREVENTING THESE INCIDENTS
THERE'S A WAY TO DO IT THERE'S
A TO YOUR BILL WE HAVE A CHANCE
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JOHN OR WHAT
ON BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
INSURANCE AGENTS BROKERS
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE WITH US
TO MADE IT -- LOCAL SCHOOL
AND STATE COST BETWEEN TEN
AND THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
THANK YOU FOR UP OPPOSED
LIVES WITH US CANNELLA THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF SCHOOL
BUSINESS OFFICIALS WE HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
BECAUSE OF THE FINANCIAL
IMPACT THIS WOULD HAVE ON
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THANK YOU
MORNING CHEN MEMBER SHIRLEY
DOWN THE HALF OF CALIFORNIA'S
COURSES THE ASIAN OPPOSE
LESS AMENDED AND I LET MY
COMMENTS WITH THAT -- PREVIOUS
TESTIMONY YOU ANY OTHER SPEAKERS
FOR AGAINST WILL GO TO FINANCE
YES -- WHAT WE'RE SENSITIVE TO
THE BILL'S OBJECTIVES THAT WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
COST PRESSURES A IN THE MILLIONS
TO LOW BILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES TO STABILIZE LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES THAT OCCURS
SIGNIFICANT LITIGATION AND
JUDGMENT COSTS ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
COST TO STATE AGENCIES AND
LOCAL NON EDUCATION AGENCIES
TO THE INCREASED AMOUNT OF
COSTS JUDGMENTS AND TO THE
EXTENT THE COSTS OR INCREASE
FOR STATE AGENCIES THIS BILL
COULD CREATE GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES TO SUPPORT THESE
AGENCIES ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING NONE WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWO EIGHTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB SIX SIX EIGHT --
COURTHOUSES SISTER SUPPORT
THEIR OPPOSITION THEIR FINAL
IS THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES THIS BILL REQUIRES
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWO POINT
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
ONGOING ALL RIGHTS SEEING
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION SIX SIX
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
SIX EIGHT ONE -- PRESIDENTIAL
PRIMARY ELECTIONS SISTER
SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
-- FILE YES WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT MAY
CREATE A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WITH UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX EIGHTY ONE
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE A. B. SEVEN
SEVEN THREE VOTER EDUCATION
NOT HIGH SCHOOLS SIR SUPPORT
MORNING TURN MEMBER SHIRLEY
DOWN BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
SCHOOL BOARD ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
SIR FILE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS IT MAY CREATE A
STATE REIMBURSABLE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
MANDATE POTENTIALLY IN THE LOW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL RESULT IN ONE TIME
AND ONGOING NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND COSTS
LIKELY IN THE LOW HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND
SECRETARY OF STATE IMPLEMENT
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS SEE NO
QUESTIONS SO WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SEVEN SEVEN THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB TEN TWENTY EIGHT
ON CLEAN ENERGY SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE IS WERE NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE SEEING NO
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TEN TWENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB TEN SIXTY
SIX -- ON UNEMPLOYMENT
-- SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ARE YOU GETTING
THERE'S OPPOSITION ALL RIGHT
YES THE BATTLE OF HASTINGS DID
HAPPEN ELIZABETH ASK OF ALL
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF SCHOOL BUSINESS OFFICIALS
AYE ALTHOUGH WE APPRECIATE THE
BILL BEING AMENDED TO REDUCE
FROM FOR WITH -- TO REDUCE THE
-- LANGUAGE FROM TWO WEEKS TO
FOUR WEEKS -- WE STILL HAVE
AN OPPOSED POSITION THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE THEIR FINANCE
YES WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE THE RESULT IN
INCREASED COST PRESSURES ON
THE UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE FUND
EXACERBATING THE CONDITION OF
THE FUNDS AND HINDERING THE
ABILITY TO BUILD A RESERVE
TO RESPOND TO VARIATIONS IN
THE ECONOMY THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES THE BILL MAY RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL PAID BENEFITS
RANGING BETWEEN EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SIX MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FROM THE U. I.
FUND SIX OTHER COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION TEN SIXTY
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
-- A. B. SIXTEEN EIGHTY
ONE ON EMPLOYEES COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IS HER SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE THE PUBLIC
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS BOARD
INDICATES THE PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL NAY RESULT IN INCREASED
WORKLOAD -- TEMPORARY WORKLOAD
COSTS ARE ESTIMATED AT TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ONGOING
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY A
ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND SHE NO QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY ONE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN LAW ENFORCEMENT THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE
IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE RESULT IN COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES THE NEED
FOR FIFTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY SIX POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE FIVE POINT
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND ONE
POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
-- AS WELL AS TWO POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
THREE TWENTY FOUR AND I'M GOING
SHE NO COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN GOT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON THE MS REYES A. B. SIX
EARLY CHILDHOOD IS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR A BI SIX IS THEIR OPPOSITION
FOR AB SIX IS THERE FILE FOR THE
SIX YES WE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT COULD
COST UP TO SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME AND ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
NON PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND TO IMPLEMENT
ITS REQUIREMENTS ADDITIONALLY
EXPANDING AND RESTRUCTURING
THE EARLY LEARNING AND CARE
DIVISION -- IS PREMATURE
GIVEN THE SIGNIFICANT INCREASE
IN STATE OPERATIONS SUPPORT
PROVIDED TO THE DIVISION AND
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB NINE EMPLOYMENT
DISCRIMINATION IS A SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE YES WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT COULD RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS DUE TO AN
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CLAIMS
FILED WITH THE DEPARTMENT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING ESTIMATES UNKNOWN
BUT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
FUND COSTS AS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL FOR EXAMPLE IF TEN PERCENT
IF THERE'S A TEN PERCENT
INCREASE IN CLAIMS THIS BILL
COULD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS SINGLE
QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION A.
B. NINE WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE
BABY THREE OH SEVEN HOMELESS
USE I. SEE SUPPORT
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT
SIR OPPOSITION SIR FILE
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT ESTABLISHES AN
ONGOING GRANT PROGRAM PROGRAM
FUNDED BY MULTIPLE VOLATILE
AND UNPREDICTABLE FUND SOURCES
AND RESULTS AN ON GOING GENERAL
FUND ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET THE
BUSINESS CONSUMER SERVICES
AND HOUSING AGENCY ESTIMATES
THE GENERAL FUND COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR
AND APPROXIMATELY FIVE FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ON GOING TO
ADMINISTER THIS PROGRAM SEE
NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB THIRTY THREE OH SEVEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB EIGHT SIX
FIVE ON RESOURCE FAMILIES
TRAINING IS THERE ARE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE YES WE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT
WOULD REQUIRE A HIGHER LEVEL
OF SERVICE ON COUNTIES THAT
WILL HAVE AN OVERALL EFFECTIVE
INCREASING GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
OF AN ADDITIONAL TWO HOURS OF
TRAINING IS ESTIMATED TO RESULT
IN COST OF FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TWO POINT ONE
MILLION WHICH IS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWO POINT
TWO MILLION DOLLARS ONE POINT
SIX MILLION WHICH IS GENERAL
FUND AND TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ONE POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS A FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
SHE NO COMMENTS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHT SIX -- AB
EIGHT SIX FIVE OVER THE SUSPENSE
AB THIRTEEN TEN TRAFFIC
VIOLATORS SCHOOLS SISTER SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE YES WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL BECAUSE OF THE
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT LOSS
OF REVENUES THAT COULD RESULT
TO THE GENERAL FUND -- AS WELL
AS COST PRESSURES TO BACK FILL
THE SPECIAL FUNDS THAT BECOME
INSOLVENT SINGLE QUESTIONS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
TEN WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MISSOURI U. S. A.
B. SIXTEEN HOMELESS CHILDREN
AND YOUTH WITH THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE THIS PROPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE IS A CREATES
COST PRESSURES OF ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND AND
TWO HUNDRED SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS NON PROPOSITION NINETEEN
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
-- ADDITIONALLY WE KNOW THAT
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
INCLUDED -- FUNDS FOR THESE
PURPOSES AND IT IS UNCLEAR
WHY ADDITIONAL POSITIONS
ARE NEEDED AT THIS TIME
NO QUESTIONS ON AB SIXTEEN
EIGHTY SIXTEEN ABOUT A SUSPENSE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIXTY
SEVEN HOMELESS INTEGRATED DATA
SIR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION IS
THERE FILE YES WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COSTS
OUTSIDE OF THE FISCAL PLAN
IS DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING
EFFORTS TO THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING AGENCY
ESTIMATES -- ONGOING COST OF
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND GENERAL
FUND ADDITIONALLY THE HOMELESS
COORDINATING AND FINANCING
COUNCIL ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE PLANNING
PHASE OF THIS PROJECT WE WOULD
NOTE HOWEVER DEPENDING ON THE
SIZE AND SCOPE OF THE PROJECT
THE PROCUREMENT AND DEVELOPMENT
COULD RESULT IN COSTS OF TEN
MILLION TO FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND A SOCIAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES JOHN OFTEN COST OF
TWO POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ON GOING FOR CASE WORKER TIME
SPENT MAINTAINING THE DATABASE
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES THREE
HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND APPROXIMATELY
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING -- FOR THIS BILL
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTY SEVERAL VOTER
SUSPENSE A. B. THIRTEEN THIRTEEN
A HIGHER EDUCATION SUPPORT
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
FILE YES WE ARE NEUTRAL ON
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT LIKELY
FURTHER ENABLES CURRENT AND
FORMER STUDENTS TO OBTAIN
THE GAINFUL EMPLOYMENT NEEDED
TO REPAY THEIR OUTSTANDING
DEBTS BUT WE DO KNOW CONCERNED
THAT THE BILL MAY INCREASE
THE FREQUENCY IN WHICH A
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS
FOR FURTHER ACCOUNTS TO DEBT
COLLECTION AGENCIES OR WITHHOLD
THE PROMISED RECOVERED AT
SHE THE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
THIRTEEN WITH OTHER SUSPENSE
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT SCHOOL
PAVEMENT OPPOSITE R. SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE YES WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE ALTHOUGH
IT IS CONTINGENT UPON A BUDGET
ACT APPROPRIATION ESTABLISHING
THIS PROGRAM LIKE THE CREATES
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURE IN THE
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON THE NUMBER OF
PARTICIPANTS AND THE AMOUNT
OF PAVEMENT CONVERGE TO GREEN
SPACE SIGNAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIFTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT WILL
GO THIS FENCE AB SEVENTEEN OH
TWO ONE HOMELESS COORDINATING
AND FINANCING SUPPORT
MORE THE GROW REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT --
OPPOSITION SIR FOR HELP
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILLS
WILL INCREASE GENERAL FUND
COSTS OUTSIDE OF THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET THE BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING
AGENCY ESTIMATES NEW STAFF
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN OH
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO MISTER BONTA
A. B. THIRTY TO FOR PROFIT
PRISONS THEIR SUPPORT
MARIO GROWN BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN STRONG SUPPORT THEIR
OPPOSITION WELL SUPPORT
STILL SUPPORT ALL RIGHT PUSH
ALL WAS RIGHT WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION SUPPORT
I THINK WE HAVE ONE MORE
SUPPORTER COMMON NANA
THE CITY WHERE ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ARE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
UTILITIES THE SERVER SO MANY
ORGANIZATIONAL PART -- CITY
WHEREVER LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE
CHAIR PIECE OF IMPORTED
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION
SHARE FILE YES WE DON'T HAVE
ANY PROOF POSITION ON THIS
BILL BUT WOULD NOTE THAT THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT
ORDERED THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
TO MAINTAIN PRISON CROWDING
AT AT OR BELOW ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN POINT FIVE PERCENT
OF THE PRISON SYSTEMS DESIGN
CAPACITY BY FEBRUARY TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE STATE HAS MET
THIS TARGET AND A STATE BELOW
THE REQUIRED PERCENTAGE BUT
BECAUSE THE STATE MUST MAINTAINS
PERCENTAGE MEASURES THAT LIMIT
THE STATE'S FLEXIBILITY IN
MEETING ITS CAPACITY -- ARE
PROBLEMATIC IT IS UNKNOWN WHAT
THE STATE'S PRISON POPULATION
WILL BE IN TWENTY TWENTY THREE
IF PRIVATE IN STATE FACILITIES
WERE NEEDED TO MAINTAIN THIS
POPULATION CAP THE BILL WOULD
LIMIT THE STATE'S FLEXIBILITY
REQUIRE THE STATE TO CONTRACT
WITH IN STATE PUBLIC COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONAL FACILITIES BUILT
ADDITIONAL STATE CAPACITY OR
IMPLEMENT MEASURES TO REDUCE
THE PRISON POPULATION ANY OF
THESE OPTIONS MAY BE COSTLY
AND IT IS PREMATURE TO LIMIT
THE STATE'S OPTIONS -- TO
CONTINUE TO MEET THE COURT
ORDER IT IS ALSO UNCLEAR IF
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THE STATE
TO CONTINUE THE USE OF PRIVATE
IN STATE RE ENTRY FACILITIES
AND IF THESE FACILITIES ARE NOT
SPECIFICALLY EXEMPT FROM THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL OVER
TWO HUNDRED INMATES WOULD HAVE
TO BE RETURNED TO STATE PRISON
FACILITIES ADDITIONALLY WE ARE
ANALYZING THE RECENT AMENDMENTS
REGARDING THE ADDITION OF
CIVIL DETENTION FACILITIES
A TO CONSIDER THE IMPACTS
OF SB SIX SIX FIVE AS WELL
SHE NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
-- OBJECTION AB THIRTY TWO WE'RE
GOING TO CSUS FENCE AB EIGHT
FOUR NINE ELECTIONS YOUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE YES WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
CHANGING THE REDISTRICTING
PROCESS FOR CITIES AND COUNTIES
-- CREATES A STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WITH UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
FOUR NINE ONE OR SUSPENSE
AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE OAKLAND
WATERFRONT REVITALIZATION SIR
SUPPORT PROPOSITION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MICHAEL PIMENTEL HERE
ON BEHALF THE PACIFIC MERCHANT
SHIPPING ASSOCIATION OPPOSITION
WERE POSTED THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT'S UNNECESSARY AT STATE AND
REGIONAL AGENCIES TARGETED
BILL ALREADY HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO PROPERLY EVALUATE THIS
PROJECT AND ALSO THE BILL WOULD
THREATEN TO DECREASE THE VALUE
OF THE TRUTH OF THE THAILAND
STRESSED THANK YOU SIR FILE
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
INDICATES THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL ARE UNKNOWN
AND LIKELY SIGNIFICANT WITH
THAT ALL THE COSTS WILL BE AND
BE REIMBURSED TO AN EXISTING
REIMBURSEMENT AGREEMENT THE
COMMISSION OF SOME MAJOR PROJECT
WILL LIKELY REQUIRE SIGNIFICANT
STAFF TIME TO MAKE BOUNDARY
DETERMINATIONS NEGOTIATED
TRUST LANDS EXCHANGE BUT THAT
THIS WORK WILL BE DONE WITH
AN EXISTING STAFF RESOURCES
ADDITIONALLY THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY CONSERVATION AND DEVELOPMENT
CONDITION COMMISSION INDICATES
-- IT WILL BE REIMBURSED FOR
THE WORK DONE -- REGARDING THIS
PROJECT WITHOUT OBJECTION
-- AB ELEVEN NINETY ONE WE
GOT A SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY ONE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
IS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS AS WELL AS CREATES A
SIGNIFICANT STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE WITH THE
SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN NINETY ONE
-- ELECTIONS SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE WE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
RESOURCES FOR THE SECRETARY OF
STATE OF APPROXIMATELY THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ON GOING -- AND MAYBE IMPOSE
A STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THAT OBJECTION SB THIRTY
NINETY ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
A. B. FIFTEEN FIFTY CRISIS
STABILIZATION IS THERE ARE THERE
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT AND UNKNOWN GENERAL
FUND COSTS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES
FIVE HUNDRED THIRTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FOUR
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AN ON GOING FOR ONE
TIME WORKLOAD ADDITIONALLY
THERE UNKNOWN COSTS FOR COUNTY
MENTAL HEALTH PLANS TO PROVIDE
CRISIS STABILIZATION SERVICES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY FOUR FIFTEEN FIFTY WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE AB SEVENTEEN OH
FIVE MEDI CAL ANYBODY SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE YES WERE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE
CENA QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION SEVENTEEN OH FIVE
ABOUT THE SUSPENSE LIVING ON
THE MISTER KALRA SB THIRTY
FIVE ANYBODY HERE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY FIVE
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION
SERRA SEARCHING NOTEBOOKS
YES WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT IN RESULT IN COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS
ESTIMATES THAT WILL RESULT IN
COST OF SEVEN HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND SEVEN HUNDRED
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB THIRTY FIVE ENCORE SUSPENSE
A. B. FIFTY NINE KALRA ELECTIONS
POLLING PLACES ARE SUPPORT
PERSONAL SERVICE WITH THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
MARIO BARONE BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
SIR FIVE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE
AN ELECTION RELATED MANDATE
REQUIRING PUBLIC BUILDINGS IN
SCHOOL BUILDINGS TO USE FOR
POLLING PLACES ARE VOTE CENTERS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTY
NINE GO TO SUSPEND SAY BEFORE
OF THREE LABOR STANDARDS
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULT
IN COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT
OF INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS
ESTIMATES COSTS BETWEEN ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO TWO POINT
NINE MILLION DOLLARS INITIALLY
AND BETWEEN ONE MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWO POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING FROM
THE LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND TO IMPLEMENT
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
THAT OBJECTION AB FOUR OH
THREE WITH A SUSPENSE AB SEVEN
THIRTY ONE HEALTHCARE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE THE DEPARTMENT
OF MANAGED HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE ONE POINT TWO MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY FIVE POINT NINE FIVE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
FIVE POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE ESTIMATES COSTS OF
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND THREE
HUNDRED SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB SEVEN THIRTY
ONE GO TO SUSPENSE A. B. SEVEN
SEVEN SIX EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION SUPPORT OPPOSITION
PINE S. THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION ESTIMATES COST OF SIX
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR TWO
YEARS AND THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
ON PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND TO IMPLEMENT THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS A FURTHER THIS
BILL COULD CREATE PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES OF APPROXIMATELY
SIXTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
SEVEN SIX FOUR THE SUSPENSE
SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO LODGING
-- SMALL PLASTIC BOTTLES
AS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE THE RESULTS IN
NEW GENERAL FUND COSTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
-- JENNIFER AND COST OF TWO
HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND THREE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
FOR NEW WORKLOAD ADDITIONALLY
BECAUSE THIS BILL REQUIRES
LOCAL AGENCIES TO TAKE ALL
REASONABLE EFFORTS TO NOTIFY
AFFECTING ESTABLISHMENTS
OF THIS BILL COULD CREATE A
PUT A REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THAT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO ABOUT A SUSPENSE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY TWO IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT IS THERE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE
BUT NO CONCERNS ON BECAUSE
THERE COULD BE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE BILL DEPENDING ON
HOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
RESPONSE TO THE LAW CHANGE
THERE COULD BE SIGNIFICANT
COST TO THE STATE AND COUNTY
PROBATION DEPARTMENTS TO
SUPERVISE -- INDIVIDUALS --
IF A CURRENT PRACTICES ARE NOT
FOLLOWED UP WE ESTIMATE
THAT BASED ON HISTORICAL
PATTERNS IF SIXTY PERCENT OF
INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE RELEASED
PAROLE -- THIS BILL COULD RESULT
IN COST APPROXIMATELY SIX OR
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION AND COST OF A
SIMILAR MAGNITUDE TO COUNTIES
THAT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
EIGHTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
GUESS WHAT WE FINISHED
OUR FIRST OF SEVEN PAGES
STUDENT FOLKS PUT YOUR FEET UP
IT'LL BE AWHILE ALL RIGHT
AB THIRTY EIGHT MISTER WORLD
ANYBODY IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION ZERO THE FILE
TAKE YOUR TIME WE HAVE ALL DAY
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS IT WILL LIKELY RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT COST PRESSURES
FOR THE GENERAL FUND THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUNDS
AND -- ANOTHER FUND AS YET
TO BE IDENTIFIED THE NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY INDICATES THE
BILL RESULTS IN ONE TIME COSTS
OF APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
A TO COMPLETE ITS REVIEW OF THE
REGIONAL CAPACITY ASSESSMENT
THE BURDEN OF FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION INDICATES COST
OF TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ONE TIME FROM THE
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION FUND
-- WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE BILL
FAILED TO IDENTIFY POTENTIAL
FUNDING SOURCE TO SUPPORT THE
FUND -- AND HOME HARDENING LOAN
AND REBATE PROGRAM GIVEN THE
MAGNITUDE OF HOME HARDENING
NEEDS ACROSS THE STATE AND
THE SCALE OF FOCUSING ON THE
NEEDS OF INDIVIDUAL HOMEOWNERS
HOMEOWNERS IT'S LIKELY THIS
BILL RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
ADDITIONAL COST PRESSURES FOR
THE GENERAL FUND GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION FUND OR ANOTHER FUND
SEEING NO QUESTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTY EIGHT WE'LL
GO TO SUSPENSE AB TWO OH
FOUR HOSPITALS SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WERE
NEUTRAL MISS MEASURE BECAUSE IT
MAY INCREASE TRANSPARENCY BUT WE
DO KNOW CONCERNED THAT AN ACTING
THIS BILL AND OTHERS AT THE
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL HEALTH DATA
AND PLANNING FUND EXPENDITURES
MAY RESULT IN THE NEED TO
INCREASE HEALTH FACILITY FEES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO OH FOUR
WHEELER SUSPENSE AB TWO NINE
ZERO HEALTHCARE PLANS IS THERE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON
THIS BILL BUT WOULD NOTE THAT
-- IT COULD INCREASE COSTS IN
THE LOW TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND DUE TO
POTENTIALLY HIGHER UTILIZATION
OF OUTPATIENT DIALYSIS SERVICES
IN THE MEDICARE PROGRAM
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO NINETY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB FOR
THIRTY SEVEN -- MOVE IN LOAN
PROGRAM MESSRS FORT OPPOSITION
FILE WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
GIVEN THE LIKELY SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING STATE COSTS AND CONCERNS
REGARDING FUND ALLOCATION AND
DISTRIBUTION THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ESTIMATE THE BILL WILL COST ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND ONE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOR
THIRTY SEVEN WITH OTHER
SUSPENSE AB EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR -- ON BUSINESS ACCESS
TO AFFORDABLE DRUGS --
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE INTO THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE THIS BILL RESULT IN
COST OF APPROXIMATELY NINE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT
SEVEN POSITIONS THAT WILL
PURSUE CIVIL ACTION AGAINST
VIOLATORS PURSUANT TO THIS BILL
WE WOULD KNOW THAT THIS BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO PURSUE -- CIVIL
ACTIONS AND ANY REQUEST FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES IS SUBJECT
TO REVIEW AND APPROVAL TO THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. EIGHT TWENTY
FOUR WHEELER SUSPENSE A. B.
NINE FIFTY FOR DENTAL SERVICES
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE IS WERE NEUTRAL ON THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT MAY ENHANCE
TRANSPARENCY -- END RESULT IN
JUST MINOR ONE TIME COSTS TO
THE STATE THAT OBJECTION
AB NINE FIFTY FOUR WE'RE GOING
TO SUSPEND SAY BE TEN FORTY
TWO BUT ACCOUNT SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE THIS BILL IS
ESTIMATED TO INCREASE MEDICAL
COSTS BY SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
SIX POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
THREE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
OF WHICH IS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AN ON GOING THAT OBJECTION
AB TEN FORTY TWO WITH OTHER
SUSPECTS AB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT
ALSO ON MEDI CAL SIR SUPPORT
GOOD MORNING MADELINE COOPER
ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO AND SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
THERE FILE THIS BILL WILL RESULT
IN COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS I
HAVE A WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
ONE POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND WHICH
IS GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS HALF OF
WHICH IS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND ON
GOING WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TEN EIGHTY EIGHT WITH --
SUSPENSE A. B. SIXTEEN FORTY
TWO ALSO ONE MEDIC COW AS YOUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IMPOSES
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES ONE
TIME COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY
TEN MILLION DOLLARS FIVE
MILLION WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
TO CONDUCT THE PREVENTIVE
SERVICES OUTREACH AND EDUCATION
PROGRAM A SPECIFIED IN THE
BILL THAT OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN
FORTY TWO OF THE SUSPENSE AB
FORTY ONE MISTER GALLAGHER ON
DISASTER RELIEF IS YOUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FILE
YES RECOGNIZING AND
ACKNOWLEDGING THIS IS A
SIGNIFICANT IMPACT FIRES
HAVE ON COMMUNITIES -- WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS
THE STATE IS ALREADY PROVIDED
COMPREHENSIVE RESPONSE AND
RECOVERY EFFORTS ALLOCATING
APPROXIMATELY TWO POINT EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS FROM THE DESK
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT TO MORE
THAN FIFTEEN STATE DEPARTMENTS
SUPPORTING AND INVESTING IN
THE LOCAL COMMUNITIES AFFECTED
BY THE CAMPFIRE AND ALTHOUGH
THIS BILLS NET FISCAL IMPACT
IS APPROXIMATELY EIGHT HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
OF THE STATE HAS ALREADY WITH
THE LOCAL MATCH REQUIREMENT
FOR DEBRIS REMOVAL FOR BUTTE
COUNTY WHICH TOTALS FORTY
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS ABOUT THE
STATE'S REQUIRE CHAIR THAT
OBJECTION AB FORTY ONE WILL GO
THE SUSPENSE AB FOUR FOUR NINE
-- TRANSPORTATION IS OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT REDIRECTS UP TO THREE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO LOCAL TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS TO THE BY LOCAL
TRANSPORTATION AGENCIES IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION IT
ALSO CIRCUMVENT THE EXISTING
PROCESS FOR PROGRAMMING
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS
THAT OBJECTION AB FOUR FOUR
NINE WE GOT A SUSPENSE VICTIMS
FRIEDMAN A. B. FORTY FOUR
FOR THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT IS PREMATURE TO
ADD OR MODIFY A ANY REQUIREMENTS
REVENUE STREAMS UNTIL THE
INDEPENDENT SERVICE BASED BUDGET
REVIEW OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE IS COMPLETE
TO ADDRESS THE FISH AND GAME
PRESERVATION FUNDS A STRUCTURAL
DEATH DEFICIT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE ESTIMATES
COST OF EIGHT HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND SEVEN HER
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
THAT OBJECTION AB FORTY
FOUR WILL GO TWO SUSPECTS
AB FIVE THREE ONE ON FOSTER
USES HER SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL -- AS A COULD
RESULT IN ANNUAL GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURE RANGING IN
THE HIGH TENS OF MILLIONS TO
LOW HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIVE THIRTY ONE WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTEEN
PART OF WATER RESOURCES SUPPORT
THANK YOU CHEN NUMBERS NIKITA
CRIED WITH THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL OR THE SPONSORED
THIS MEASURE AND STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SIR OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES AND IT IS NOT CLEAR
THAT THE PENALTY REVENUES
WOULD EXCEED THE COST OF THE
PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES ESTIMATES A ONE TIME
COST OF THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND WITH ON
GOING COST OF TWO HUNDRED NINETY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
AND BY THE BILL DOES ESTABLISH
A PENALTIES ACCOUNT UP WITHIN
THE GENERAL FUND -- IT IS
NOT CLEAR THAT THE REVENUE
WILL FULLY OFFSET SOME OF THE
DEPARTMENTS COSTS THAT OBJECTION
AB FOURTEEN FIFTEEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
STONE AB FORTY FIVE INMATES
SISTER SUPPORT OPPOSITION
GOOD MORNING TO DÂN WONG
REPRESENTING STARTING OVER
INC A NON PROFIT THAT SERVICES
SYSTEM ACTED SYSTEM IMPACTED
PEOPLE AND BOTH LA IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY AND THE RIVERSIDE
CHAPTER OF ALL OF US ARE
NONE IN ORGANIZING INITIATIVE
FOUNDED BY FORMERLY INCARCERATED
PEOPLE WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT EIGHT OTHERS IN
SUPPORT WHEN THE WATER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT THERE ANY OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES FOR NEUTRONS MEASURE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FORTY FIVE
A LOT OF SUSPENSE AB TWO FIVE
THREE -- REMOTE COURT REPORTING
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT LIMITS THE ABILITY
OF OTHER COURTS TO USE REMOTE
COURT REPORTING -- PROHIBITING
OTHER COURTS FROM IMPLEMENTING
-- COURT REPORTING REMOTE COURT
REPORTING THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
ESTIMATES THAT THE WOULD HAVE
COST IN EXCESS OF TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO
THAT OBJECTION AB TWO FIVE
THREE WITH A SUSPENSE AB THREE
SEVEN SIX STUDENT LOANS
SUPPORT PUSHOVERS IN THE
UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
WE'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT
FOREVER ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE DON'T HAVE A POSITION
ON THIS BILL BUT NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF BUSINESS OVERSIGHT
ANTICIPATES COSTS OF ONE POINT
SIX MILLION DOLLARS FINANCIAL
INSTITUTION INSTITUTIONS FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND NOT
GOING TO CREATE A NEW DIVISION
FOR STUDENT LENDING WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT THE DEPARTMENT
ALSO KNOWS THAT DUE TO PENDING
LITIGATION THEY'VE BEEN ON AN
ABLE TO COLLECT REVENUE UNDER
THE STUDENT LOAN SERVICING ACT
AND BECAUSE OF THIS THERE MAY BE
A NEED TO REQUEST GENERAL FUND
TO COMPLY WITH THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ANTICIPATES COSTS
OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND ON GOING FINALLY THE BUREAU
FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION OFFICE OF STUDENT
ASSISTANCE RELIEF ANTICIPATES
MINOR UNANSWERABLE COSTS
THAT OBJECTION AB THREE
SEVEN SIX OVER THE SUSPENSE
AB FOR ELEVEN OUR SANTA
CRUZ SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS BY ALLOWING THE CITY
OF SANTA CRUZ TO EXPAND PROCEEDS
FROM BONDS ISSUED SUBSEQUENT TO
DECEMBER THIRTIETH TWENTY TEN
THIS BILL REDUCES THE OUT YOUR
ANTICIPATED PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND SAVINGS BY
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR AND
IN ADDITION IT DEPRIVES OTHER
AFFECTED TAXING ENTITIES --
OR OF RESIDUAL DISTRIBUTIONS
OF FINALLY ENACTMENT OF THIS
LEGISLATION WILL CREATE A
PRECEDENT FOR SUCCESSOR AGENCIES
TO CIRCUMVENT THE REDEVELOPMENT
DISSOLUTION PROCESS THAT
OBJECTION NAY BEFORE ELEVEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE A. B. TO
-- DATA PORTHOLES THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE WE
BELIEVE THERE ARE MINIMAL COST
TO STATE AND LOCAL ENTITIES
RELATED TO SUBMITTING THE
REPORTS TO THE LEGISLATURE IN
ELECTRONIC FORMAT HOWEVER WE
DO HAVE COST CONCERNS RESULTING
THE BILL'S BROAD REQUIREMENT
THAT ALL DATA SETS USED TO
GENERATE REPORTS SUBMITTED TO
THE LEGISLATURE BE POSTED TO
THE PORTAL IN ACCORDANCE WITH
APPLICABLE DISCLOSURE LAWS BUT
WITHOUT REGARD TO FEASIBILITY
OR VALUE -- AT A STATEWIDE
LEVEL -- AN ESTIMATE OF WHAT
THIS WOULD COST -- WOULD
RESULT IN ONGOING ON BUDGET
EXPENDITURES IN EXCESS OF TWO
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
ANNUALLY OUT
OF THE ACTION AB EIGHT OH TWO
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY FIVE THEIR SUPPORT
THE GOOD MORNING JORDAN
ALONG REPRESENTING STARTING
OVER INC A NON PROFIT THAT
SERVICES SYSTEM ACT AND PEOPLE
FROM IMPACTED PEOPLE IN BOTH
LA AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY AS WELL
AS RIVERSIDE CHAPTER OF ALL
OF US ARE NINE IN ORGANIZING
INITIATIVE -- FOUNDED BY
FORMALLY INCARCERATED PEOPLE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
THE ONE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN STRONG
SUPPORT PERSONAL
SEVEN WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THEIR OPPOSITION FIVE
MINUTES YES WE ESTIMATE
THAT THE TOTAL IMPACT OF THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN FUTURE
YOUR SAVINGS IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS ARE LOW MILLIONS
OF GENERAL FUND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY WE WOULD NOTE THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION ANTICIPATES A
COST OF APPROXIMATELY FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN THE FIRST TWO YEARS
OF IMPLEMENTATION DECLINING TO
NINE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
THIRD YEAR TO PROVIDE TRAINING
AND RECALCULATE USED OFFENDER
PAROLE OF ELIGIBILITY DATES
AS WELL AS OTHER ACTIVITIES
RELATED TO THIS MEASURE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB NINE SIXTY
FIVE WILL ASSIST FENCE WILL
MOVE ON A. B. EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WHICH IS A COMMITTEE BILLS OR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
ARE NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE THAT
OBJECTION AB EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON MR
TANG AB SIXTY EIGHT ON LAND USE
SUPPORT PROPOSITION
FINANCE AND NOT WITHSTANDING
THE GOALS OF THIS BILL WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THE MEASURE AS A
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT
ESTIMATES COSTS OF THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR AND
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ESTIMATES COSTS OF ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
THE FIRST YEAR AND ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ON GOING TO
ENFORCE THE BILL'S REGULATIONS
AND IMPLEMENT GUIDELINES
RELATED TO ACCESS READ WILLING
UNITS -- AND ANY REQUESTS FOR
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES -- WILL BE
SUBJECT TO REVIEW AND APPROVAL
THROUGH THE ANNUAL BUDGET
PROCESS THAT OBJECTION
AB SIXTY WITH A SUSPENSE AB ONE
SIX ONE ON PAPER WASTE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE
I WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL
-- BUT NO CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR INCREASED GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES TO ENFORCE
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
INITIALLY AND SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT
OF RESOURCES RECYCLING --
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH DON'T ESTIMATE ANY
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL
BUT OBJECTION AB ONE SIXTY
ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE SB FIVE
TWELVE ON MEDIC COUNTS OR SPORT
OPPOSITION FILE YES WE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT AND
UNKNOWN GENERAL FUND COSTS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH -- AN UNKNOWN
GENERAL FUND COST TO COUNTIES
THAT OBJECTION AB FIVE TWELVE
AGO TO SUSPENSE A. B. SEVEN
NINETY TWO ON RECYCLING
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE CAL RECYCLE AS MAKES COST
OF NINE HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS INITIALLY AND
NINE HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING FROM THE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
FUND TO ANALYZE SUBMITTED DATA
CONDUCT REVIEWS DEVELOP AUDIT
REFERRALS AND ENFORCE THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL WE WOULD
NOTE THAT THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING FUND IS QUITE VOLATILE
AND THAT EVEN SLIGHT CHANGES IN
REVENUES ARE EXPENDITURES CAN
RESULT IN FUND BALANCE DECREASES
THAT MAY TRIGGER PROGRAM
REDUCTIONS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SEVENTY TWO WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE A. B. TEN -- ONE
-- CHILDCARE SEARCH FOR
OPPOSITION FINANCE THIS REPORT
MEASURE HAS IS PREMATURE A TO
MAKE CHANGES TO EARLY LEARNING
AND CARE DATA SYSTEMS GIVEN THE
VARIOUS PROJECTS AND RESEARCH
IN THIS AREA THAT ARE CURRENTLY
UNDER WAY -- ALTHOUGH THIS BILL
IS CONTINGENT UPON A BUDGET
ACT APPROPRIATION WE ESTIMATE
THAT THE COST WOULD BE IN
THE LOW HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS NOT PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THAT
OBJECTION AB THOUSAND ONE WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY THIRD PARTY FOOD DELIVERY
IS OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL'S REQUIREMENTS CREATE
NEW GENERAL FUND COSTS FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET --
PUBLIC HEALTH INDICATES ON
GOING GENERAL FUND COST OF
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS BEGINNING IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT OBJECTION
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX -- SURPLUS LAND IS
THEIR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- DAVID NEVIN
ON BEHALF OF THE SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY TO ME COLLEGE DISTRICT
WE'RE HOLD US OF -- SORRY
OPPOSITION UNLESS AMENDED TO
JUST EXEMPTS THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND -- ANYTHING
THAT'S ALREADY SUBJECTED TO
THE EDUCATION CODE WITH REGARD
TO THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
THANK YOU SERRA
FINANCE YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS IT IMPOSES REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATED COSTS AND LOCAL
AGENCIES THE SCOPE OF THESE
COSTS IS UNKNOWN BUT MAY BE
SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
IT WOULD REQUIRE TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN THE FIRST YEAR WITH ANNUAL
ONGOING COSTS OF TWO MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND THAT
OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY
SIX WILL GO THE SUSPENSE MISTER
COOPER HAS ONE BILL AB ONE THREE
SEVEN YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE'RE WE'RE
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE
THAT OBJECTION AB ONE THREE
SEVEN RESTAURANTS MISS QUIRK
SILVA AB ONE THREE NINE
EMERGENCY HOUSING SIR SUPPORT
THE WONDER WHAT CALIFORNIA
CATHOLIC CONFERENCE IN SUPPORT
SIR OPPOSITION ZERO FIVE
YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE THE RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND IMPACTS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN THE FIRST YEAR EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND
COST OF THREE HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONGOING THAT OBJECTION
AB ONE THREE NINE WITH A
SUSPENSE AB THREE THREE SEVEN
ON FOSTER CARE AS THEIR SUPPORT
THE MEASURE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPPORT TROUT POSITION
SIR FILE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE -- IN MILK
IT MAY RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS RANGING
FROM ONE POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS UP TO THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
UP TO THREE THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THERE AFTER ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL RESULTS IN GENERAL FUND
SAVINGS -- BUT THAT IS DUE
TO -- THIS MEASURE NEGATING
NEGOTIATED BUDGET AGREEMENT
BETWEEN THE ADMINISTRATION
AND LEGISLATURE RELATING TO
EMERGENCY CARE COVER ASSISTANCE
PAYMENTS THAT OBJECTION
AB THREE THREE SEVEN ALTHOUGH
TO SUSPENSE AB ONE SIXTY THREE
CRISTINA GARCIA ON UNACCOMPANIED
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL AS THE ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
ASSOCIATED WITH IT CREATES
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT WERE
NOT INCLUDED IN TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES ESTIMATES COST
OF FOUR HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND THREE HUNDRED
SEVENTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB ONE SIXTY
THREE WITH OTHER SPENT A BE
SIX FORTY NINE GAMBLING CONTROL
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE THE GAMBLING CONTROL
COMMISSION ESTIMATES MINOR
OBSERVABLE COST REVISED
REGULATIONS -- ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE INDICATES
COST OF TWO HUNDRED SEVEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWO HUNDRED SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO A AND ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND I'M GOING
OBJECTION AB SIX FORTY
NINE OF THE SUSPENSE AB ONE
SIXTY SIX -- WE'VE MOVED ON
TO MR GABRIEL -- VIOLENCE
PREVENTIVE SERVICES IS
THEIR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
IS THERE FILE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE ASSUMING
FEDERAL FINANCIAL PARTICIPATION
IT WOULD RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT -- A BASED ON THE BILL'S
PROVISIONS OF THE BILL WOULD
LIKE THE RESULT IN COSTS IN
THE LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES TO ADMINISTER
BUT OBJECTION AB ONE SIXTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB SEVEN
FIFTY TWO ON TRANSIT STATIONS
AS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE WE DON'T HAVE AN APPROVED
POSITION ON THIS BILL AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
DOESN'T ANTICIPATE ANY INCREASED
COSTS -- BUT WE WOULD KNOW THAT
THIS BILL WILL LIKELY RESULT
IN HIGHER COSTS FOR THE STATE
AND LOCAL TRANSIT FACILITY
PROJECTS AND WHILE MANY OF
THE CONSTRUCTION OR RENOVATION
PROJECTS ARE GENERALLY OPTIONAL
THIS BILL MAY CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE BECAUSE
A LOCAL TRANSIT AGENCIES MAY
BE REQUIRED TO DO UNRELATED
RENOVATIONS -- WHETHER FOR HATE
FOR HEALTH AND SAFETY REASONS
FINALLY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY DOES NOT ANTICIPATE
A FISCAL IMPACT AS ALL THE
PLANNED -- RAIL STATIONS
ALREADY INCLUDE LACTATION
ROOMS AS PART OF THEIR DESIGN
THAT JACKSON AB SEVEN
FIFTY TWO A SUSPENSE A. B.
ELEVEN THIRTY TWO CALLER
IDENTIFICATION IS THERE -- ARE
THERE ANY SUPPORTERS OPPOSERS
FILE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURES IT CREATES ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES AND
FEDERAL LAW ALREADY PROHIBITS
THE ACTIVITIES DESCRIBED IN
THIS BILL THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COST OF
AROUND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONGOING
THE P. C. DOES NOT ANTICIPATE
ANY FISCAL IMPACTS FROM THIS
BILL -- AND THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
INDICATES THIS BILL MAY RESULT
IN MINOR ANSWERABLE COSTS
TO THE TRIAL COURT'S WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ELEVEN THIRTY
TO ABOUT A SUSPENSE MOVIE ON
MR CHOW AB ONE SEVEN THREE
MOBILE HOMES SISTER SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
THE RESULTS AND POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
TO THE HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT AND
AN UNKNOWN INCREASE IN THE
STATE'S PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND APPLICATION
THAT OBJECTION AB ONE SEVENTY
THREE RATHER SUSPENSE AB
THREE EIGHTY FOUR -- PRIVACY
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULTS
IN COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
STATE'S CURRENT FISCAL PLAN
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST OF TWO HUNDRED
FOURTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND THREE HUNDRED SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB THREE EIGHTY
FOUR WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE AB
THREE NINETY SEVEN VEHICLES
DRIVING UNDER THE INFLUENCE
IS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT CREATES
A POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE THAT
OBJECTION AB THREE NINETY
SEVEN WITH A SPEND SAVE ME
NINE SEVENTY SIX ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE -- IS THERE SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE THE RESULTS IN ON BUDGET
GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES OF
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THROUGH JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO
ESTABLISH AND OPERATE THE
COMMISSION BUT EVERYBODY
MISSED AN OPPORTUNITY TO COME
UP AND TALK ABOUT ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE IN THE LEGISLATURE
I WAS WAITING FOR SOMEBODY
BUT NOBODY ALL RIGHT MOVING ON
TO A. B. SO THAT -- AB
NINE SEVENTY SIX WILL GO TO
-- SUSPENSE WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWELVE OH TWO PRIVACY
SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
RESULTS AT A MINIMUM IN ON
BUDGET GENERAL FUND COSTS
IN THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS DURING TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND ON GOING
THAT OBJECTION AB TWO OH TWO
WILDERNESSES FENCE THAT
ONLY LEAVES FIVE PAGES TO GO
ALL RIGHT AB TWELVE EIGHTY
ONE ALSO ON PRIVACY SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THE RESULTS IN ON BUDGET AND
ONGOING COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS DUPLICATES
EXISTING STATUTES I REDUCES
THE PENALTIES ASSOCIATED WITH
VIOLATIONS OF EXISTING STATUTES
A AND DILUTES THE POTENTIAL
FUNDING AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT THE
ENFORCEMENT OF THOSE EXISTING
STATUTES FOR THAT OBJECTION
AB TWELVE EIGHTY ONE WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE A. B. SIXTEEN NINETY
SIX ON INTERNATIONAL TRADE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT WILL RESULT
IN ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND
COSTS AND IS DUPLICATIVE OF
GO THIS IS EXISTING AUTHORITY
AGO IS ESTIMATED ANNUAL COST
OF BETWEEN ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO ESTABLISH THE PROCEDURES
OUTLINED IN THIS BILL AND IN
THE EVENT AN INTERNATIONAL
OFFICES APPROVED AND ESTABLISH
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY WILL BE NEEDED
FOR EACH OFFICE DEPENDING ON
THE LOCATION SIZE AND SCOPE
OF THE INTERNATIONAL TRADE
OFFICE WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SIXTY NINETY SIX WILL
GO THE SUSPENSE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO MISTER GIBSON AB
ONE SEVEN FIVE FOSTER CARE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE -- AS A MOAT MAY
IMPOSE SIGNIFICANT COST
TO THE GENERAL FUND --
FOR EXACT COSTS ARE UNKNOWN OF
WE NOTE THAT A PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION -- TO
FOSTER USE -- COULD CREATE
ADDITIONAL FUNDS UNDER THE
PROVISIONS OF PROPOSITION THIRTY
WE MISS SOMEONE GO AHEAD ARE
THE CARRERA PRESENT IN THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE SEVEN FIVE AGO
SUSPENSE A. B. SEVEN FORTY EIGHT
-- SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE THIS BILL
RESULT IN A NET INCREASE IN
ASSISTANCE AND ADMINISTRATIVE
COSTS TO THE COUNTIES IN THE
RANGE OF TWO HUNDRED SIXTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ANNUALLY ASSOCIATE WITH
AN INCREASE OF APPROXIMATELY
SEVENTY NINE MINOR DEPENDENCE
THAT OBJECTION AB SOME
FORTY EIGHT WITH A SUSPENSE
A. B. SEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN
-- SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT MAY RESULT
IN A STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THAT WILL GENERATE SIGNIFICANT
UNKNOWN COSTS TO THE STATE
WELL JACKSON AB SEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN AGO SUSPENSE AB EIGHT OH
THREE PEACE OFFICERS AS THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE STATE'S FISCAL PLANNED
AND THEY'RE ALREADY EXISTING
INTERNAL POLICIES THAT
GOVERN PEER SUPPORT PROGRAMS
SENATE JACKSON AVIATOR THREE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE A. B. NINE
FIFTY FIVE WATER SYSTEM NEEDS
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE AT THE WATER BOARD
IS NOT PROVIDED FISCAL
ESTIMATE AT THE TIME AT THIS
TIME -- HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT
THE WATER BOARD COSTS ARE
LIKELY MINIMAL AND RELATED TO
REACHING AGREEMENTS WITH WATER
REPLENISHMENT DISTRICTS THAT
OBJECTION EIGHTY NINE FIFTY
FIVE ABOUT A SUSPENSE A. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTY FOR JUVENILE
COURT SCHOOLS SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS
EXISTING LAW ALREADY REQUIRES
COUNTY OFFICES OF EDUCATION
AND THE COUNTY PROBATION
DEPARTMENTS TO DEVELOP A JOINT
TRANSITION POLICY WE ESTIMATE
COSTS TO BE IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS TO LOW MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS EACH PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT AND NOT PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND DUE TO THE
EXPANDED IN MORE DETAIL JOINT
POLICY TRANSITION REQUIREMENTS
PLACED ON THESE AGENCIES WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN FIFTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE A. B.
FIFTEEN FORTY FOUR ANY PRIOR
PARA MEDICINES UP TRY ASH
YES SUPPORT MISTER TURN
MEMBERS SYLVIA SOLUTION ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES AUTHORITY REPORTS THIS
BILL OF RESULTS IN COSTS OF
SIX HUNDRED NINETY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
EIGHT HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND YOU
LIVE THERE AFTER TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
THAT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN FORTY
FOUR WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
ON TO MS AGUILAR HURRY AB TWO
TWO EIGHT IS THERE SUPPORT
MATALIN COOPER ON BEHALF
OF THE US HEMP ROUND TABLE
AND OTHER HEMP AND CANNABIS
COALITIONS IN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIRMAN MY NAME IS
MICHAEL GREEN I AM -- WITH
CDS CONSULTING A REPRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE GRANGE ONE
OF THE OLDEST ORGANIZATIONS
WORLD SUSAN ORGANIZATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA WHO'S FOR OF DEALS
IN MEMBERS MEETING MONTHLY AND
ONE OF ITS EIGHTY PLUS LOCAL
GRANGE HALLS LOCATED IN FORTY
CALIFORNIA COUNTIES IN ALMOST
EVERY LEGISLATIVE DISTRICTS
SUPPORT TO PRODUCTION AND
USE OF HIM THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS HOLY
MEASURE BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
WEST HOLLYWOOD IT'S SUPPORT
OPPOSITION BRISTOL SUPPORT BILL
I'M UPSWING RICHMAN EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR CALIFORNIA HEMP
DISASSOCIATION AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE CURRENT VERSION
HOWEVER I THINK THERE NEEDS TO
BE ADJUSTED SOME ADJUSTMENTS
WITH REGARD TO A DIVERSIONARY
PROGRAM FOR HELP FARMERS INTO
THE -- CANNABIS MARKET IF THIS
IS TO WORK CORRECTLY AND I'M
ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT -- TOO
MUCH OF A BURDEN OF TESTING ON
OUR FARMERS SHOULD BE DONE AT
THE PROCESSING LEVEL THANK YOU
IT'S YOUR TURN MEMBERS ON
TRACY STEVENS ON BEHALF OF
NATURAL LIFE SCIENCES IN
OPPOSITION AND ALSO NOR CAL
CANNABIS IN OPPOSITION AND LESS
AMENDED THANK YOU FINANCE
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL CREATES NEW COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH INDICATES FOOD SAFETY
FUND COST OF EIGHT HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
EIGHT HUNDRED FORTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THERE AFTER
AS WELL AS CANNABIS CONTROL
FUND BECAUSE OF NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ANNUALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS INDICATES
CANNABIS CONTROL FUND COSTS OF
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWO POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND IS THERE AFTER FOR
LABORATORY TESTING FEES AND
ADDITIONAL STAFF TO ENFORCE
THE PROVISIONS OF THE BILL
ADDITIONALLY THE PARTNER FOOD
AND AGRICULTURE REPORTS COST
OF TWO POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
TO UNDERGO A REVIEW OF HEMP
PRODUCTS FOR ANIMAL FOOD
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO TWO
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
RESEARCHERS CAN YOU TAKE
OVER FOR A COUPLE MINUTES
YEAH NOT
TELL ME TAKE YOUR CALLS TOO YEAH
ALL RIGHT SIR NEXUS AB THREE
TWENTY FOUR IS THAT CORRECT YES
OKAY AB THREE TWENTY FOUR A YEAR
CURRY CHILD SERVICES STATEMENTS
ANY OF IN OPPOSITION
ARE IN SUPPORTER IN OPPOSITION
AND TO THE DESK PLEASE THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE NON PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES IN THE LOW TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS AS IT
EXPANDS EXISTING AB TWO TWELVE
SECOND PROGRAM TO INCLUDE NEW
TYPES OF PROVIDERS HOWEVER
NO ADDITIONAL FUNDING WAS
PROVIDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT FOR THIS PURPOSE
ADDITIONALLY ACCORDING TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ONE ONE HUNDRED FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ONGOING NON
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT GENERAL
FUND COSTS FOR THE DEPARTMENT
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THE BILL ANYTHING ELSE
AND WITH US WITHOUT OBJECTION
AGO THE SUSPENSE NEXT ONES A. B.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR AND YOUR CAREER
HEALTH COVERAGE TELE HEALTH
ANY SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS
IT WILL RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDING THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES DOESN'T
ANTICIPATE A FISCAL IMPACT
FOR FEE FOR SERVICE MEDICARE
I'LL BUT KNOWS THE BILL MAY
INCREASE STATE COSTS FOR MANAGED
CARE PLANS AND SHOULD PLANCY
CAPITATION RATE INCREASES THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM ESTIMATES THE
FISCAL IMPACT UP TO FORTY TWO
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE MEDI
CAL MANAGED CARE PLANS AS A
RESULT OF HIGHER RATES AND
UTILIZATION ADDITIONALLY CHIPPER
THE TROOPER ANALYSIS OF THIS
BILL ESTIMATES FOUR POINT NINE
MILLION DOLLARS IN INCREASED
COSTS TO THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES RETIREMENT SYSTEMS
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS TO
HIGHER RATES AND UTILIZATION
FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
MANAGED HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS MANAGED
CARE FUN IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ONE POINT SEVEN MILLION
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND I'M GOING
ANNUALLY WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
WILL GO TO SUSPEND SECTION IS
AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO YEAR
CURRY MASTER PLAN FOR AGING ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT IS
DEPLETED OF EXISTING EFFORTS
OF WE ESTIMATE THAT THIS BILL
RESULT IN COST OF FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO FOR THREE
POSITIONS ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURES LIKELY IN
THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO INCREASE WAGES AND
BENEFITS OF HOME CARE WORKERS
SERVING MEDI CAL BENEFICIARIES
ACTION THAT WILL ALSO GO TO
SUSPENSE THE NEXT ONE IS AB
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR A YEAR
CURRY MEDI CAL TELEHEALTH ANY
WITNESSES SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT CREATES A STAKEHOLDER
WORKGROUP BUT THE DEPARTMENT
-- DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES COULD UTILIZE ONE OF
ITS MANY EXISTING STAKEHOLDER
WORK GROUPS AND OTHER ENGAGEMENT
EFFORTS TO RECEIVE GUIDANCE ON
IMPLEMENTING THIS BILL THANK
YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE THE NEXT
BILL IS BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER BRO
HE HAS ONE BILL AB TWO THIRTY
DISABLED VETERAN BUSINESS
ENTERPRISES WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
THE BILL REQUIRE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE SERVICE REVOLVING FUND ON
GOING TO PROCESS THE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION REQUIRED BY THIS
BILL ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
ALSO RESULTS IN UNKNOWN BUT
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COSTS
FOR ALL CONTRACTING STATE
AGENCIES TOGETHER PAYMENT DATA
AT THE TIME THE CONTRACT IS
COMPLETED THANK YOU WITHOUT
OBJECTION THAT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE NEXT BILL IS AB
TWO FORTY THREE COM MOTOR
DOVE IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD MORNING STILL
PARTIAL STRUGGLE WITH THE
UC SINICIZATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU MARIO GUERRERO
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION INSTRUCTS
SUPPORT ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YES WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
IT IMPOSES SIGNIFICANT STATE
AND LOCAL COST IMPLEMENT A
SCHEDULE OF LIONEL BIENNIAL
TRAINING -- AND MAY IMPOSE IT
WAS STATE REIMBURSABLE MANDATE
THANK YOU WITHOUT OBJECTION
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SUSPEND
SYNNEX BILLS AB TWELVE
FIFTY FOUR CALM WATERS OF
BOBCATS TAKE PROHIBITION
WITNESSES IN OP -- IN SUPPORT
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OF MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MARK
SMITH ON HALF THE CALIFORNIA
WATERFOWL ASSOCIATION IN
ADDITION TO OUR CONCERNS THAT
THIS SORT OF YOU SURPLUS THE
RIGHT OF THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION -- THE FISCAL COST
IS SIGNIFICANT THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE IS UNDER
-- A SERVICE BASED BUDGETING
AUDIT AT THIS TIME IN PART
BECAUSE THEY HAVE A STRUCTURAL
DEFICIT SO IT NOT FOR THE MONEY
TO FUND THIS PROGRAM AS THE BILL
REQUIRES IN ADDITION WE THINK
THAT YOU WOULD DO THE STUDY
FIRST AND THEN IMPLEMENT THE
POLICY EVEN IF THE FUNDING WERE
TO BECOME AVAILABLE THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
-- MEMBERS COMMITTEE KATHY
LYNCH REPRESENTING SAFARI CLUB
INTERNATIONAL NATIONAL SHOOTING
SPORTS FOUNDATION OUTDOOR SPORTS
AND COALITION ALL IN OPPOSITION
CONCUR WITH THE PRIOR WITNESSES
COMMENTS IN WHICH IS TO INDICATE
THAT THE BUDGET REVIEW WAS
SOMETHING THAT WAS UNDERTAKEN
LAST YEAR IN THE BUDGET
IN AS A THREE YEAR PROCESS
WERE FISH AND WILDLIFE IS IS
LOOKING AT THEIR BUDGET AND
SO WE THINK THAT PROCESS NEEDS
TO PLAY OUT FIRST THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RAUCOUS
BECOME HALF THE CALIFORNIA
RIFLE PISTOL SOLUTION IN THE
NRA WERE IN STRONG OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL THIS BILL TAKES
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AWAY FROM
ACT CRITTERS THAT REQUIRE THIS
DATA REQUIRE THESE STUDIES
BOBCATS ARE ALIVE AND DOING
WELL IN CALIFORNIA ADDITIONALLY
WE FILL THESE DECISIONS SHOULD
BE BASED ON SCIENCE AND LEFT
IN THE HANDS OF THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION THOSE GOVERNOR
APPOINTED INDIVIDUALS WITH THE
EXPERTISE AND THE PUBLIC FORM
TO HEAR THIS MATTER THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
BECAUSE IT COULD EXACERBATE THE
FISHING GAME PRESERVATION FUNDS
STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE WHICH WOULD
HINDER THE DEPARTMENT'S ABILITY
TO CARRY OUT CORPS PROGRAMS
AS PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED -- IT
IS PREMATURE TO ADD OR MODIFY
ANY PROGRAMMATIC REQUIREMENTS
OR REVENUE STREAMS UNTIL THE
INDEPENDENT SERVICE BASED
BUDGET REVIEW THIS DEPARTMENT
IS COMPLETE OTHER DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES COSTS OF
TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN FISCAL YEAR TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWO POINT FOUR MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND I'M
GOING THANK YOU I AGREE
WITH THE A WITNESSES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT'S
GOOD NEWS THIS WILL ALSO BE
ON GOING TO SUSPENSE THE NEXT
BILL IS AB FOURTEEN HUNDRED
BY KAMLAGER-DOVE FIRE FIGHTING
EQUIPMENT SAFETY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT FURNACES IN OPPOSITION
DIFFERENT FINANCE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
THIS BILL RESULT IN COST FOUR
POINT SIX MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS FOR STAFF RESOURCES
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL MAY
RESULT IN A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
LOS ANGELES COUNTY TO WORK
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
TO DEVELOP THE SPECIFIED
STUDY WITHOUT OBJECTION THIS
BILL WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AND I'LL HAND THE CHAIR BACK
TO THE CHAIR JEFF
THANK YOU FOR STEPPING IN
AND SO WE ARE MOVING ON AB
TWO FIFTY EIGHT WERE MOVING TO
MISTER JONES SAWYER WILL SUPPORT
YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS THE LEGISLATURE
CANNOT ALLOCATE PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR FUNDS AS PROPOSED
UNDER THE INITIATIVE PROHIBITED
THE LEGISLATURE FROM MAKING
CHANGES TO THE ALLOCATIONS TO
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR -- PRIOR
TO JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
EIGHT OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES HAS ALREADY
IDENTIFIED USES FOR THESE
FUNDS FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY FISCAL YEAR AND ON GOING
ADDITIONALLY AS A RESULT THIS
BILL CREATES ON GOING COSTS
IN THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS NOT PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THIS BILL WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWO FIVE EIGHT WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING ON THE A. B.
TWELVE NINETY ONE CANNABIS
SAYS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS INDICATES A MINOR AND
SEVERAL COSTS FOR THE BUREAU
OF CANNABIS CONTROL TO MODIFY
ITS REGULATIONS THE DEPARTMENT
OF FOOD AND AGRICULTURE
ESTIMATES MINOR SEVERAL COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL AND
FINALLY IT IS LIKELY THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
MAIN KERR SOME MINOR OF SEVERAL
COSTS RELATED TO THIS MEASURE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
NINETY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY FOUR --
OLYMPIC PUBLIC SAFETY COMMAND
-- PLACER SUPPORT THE ONLY
A SOLUTION ON BEHALF OF
LA TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT THE
ORGANIZING COMMITTEE FOR THE
TWENTY TWENTY OLYMPICS IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU SHOP POSITION
FINANCE COST TO THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE
NOT UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME --
HOWEVER THE ACTIVITIES REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL ARE LIKELY
INAPPROPRIATE USE OF FEDERAL
FUNDING CALLAWAY YES RECEIVED TO
HOMELAND SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FOUR WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE
MOVING TO MISTER CHIU CAL
WORKS A. B. TWO EIGHTY THREE
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN STATE FISCAL PLAN
WE ESTIMATE THE BILL RESULT IN
COST OF APPROXIMATELY TEN POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND FOUR POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER THIS BILL ALSO RESULT
IN ONE TIME AUTOMATION COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWO EIGHT
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE A. B.
SEVEN TWENTY NINE ON CORPORATE
RECYCLING SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS FOR NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE A CAL RECYCLE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED NINETEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS -- IN THE
FIRST YEAR AND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING FROM THE CARPET STORAGE
ACCOUNT THAT OBJECTION
AB SEVEN TWENTY I WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE A. B. TEN FIFTY TWO
-- PEACE OFFICERS AS THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT IMPOSES STATE AND
LOCAL COST EMPLOYMENT TRAINING
CONTENT BY SPECIFIED DEADLINES
THE PEACE OFFICER STANDARDS
AND TRAINING ANTICIPATES
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE
STATE PENALTY FUN ADDITIONALLY
AT THIS BILL MAY IMPOSE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE REQUIRING
PEACE OFFICERS TO WASH THE
HATE CRIME VIDEO ON OR BEFORE
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN
FIFTY TWO A SUSPENSE MOVIE
TO MISTER COOLEY AB TWO
NINETY SIX KLEIMAN INNOVATION
IS OUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT IS NOT COST
EFFECTIVE AND DUPLICATIVE OF
MANY OF THE STATE'S EXISTING
PROGRAMS TO COMP COMBAT
CLIMATE CHANGE THE FRANCHISE
TAX BOARD ESTIMATES OF THIS
BILL WOULD REDUCE GENERAL
FUND REVENUES BY A THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ADDITIONALLY THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNCIL ESTIMATES --
COSTS THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH WOULD REQUIRE FIVE
STAFF MEMBERS AT A COST OF FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY BEGINNING
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THAT OBJECTION AB TWO NINETY
SIX RECURSOS FRANCE AB TEN
SIXTY EIGHT -- JUVENILES
AS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ESTIMATE THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE MILLIONS TO
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY FOR COUNTIES TO COMPLY
WITH THE REPORTING NOTIFICATION
AND PARTICIPATION PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL THAT OBJECTION
AB TEN SIXTY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
A. B. TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT
ALSO ON CANNABIS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THE BUREAU ALREADY HAS A PROCESS
ESTABLISHING REGULATIONS THAT
IS IN PLACE FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO VERIFY THE DELIVERY IS
BEING MADE BY LICENSE RETAILER
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
EIGHTY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE TO MISTER QUIRK --
AB THREE TWENTY PRESS CONTROL
IS THEIR SUPPORT IN ASKING
ON BEHALF MOSQUITO AND VECTOR
CONTROL ASSOCIATION SPONSORED
THE BILL BILL SIMPLY SEEKS TO
CODIFY AN EXISTING PROGRAM AS
FOR YOUR SUPPORT SIR OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WE WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT CODIFIES
THE REQUIREMENTS TO SUPPORT THE
EXISTING CAL SERVE PROGRAM AND
COULD CREATE GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES LIKELY IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS TO LOW MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO SUPPORT THE PROGRAM
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THREE
TWENTY WITH THE SUSPENSE A
BEFORE -- TO THE STATE WATER
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD SIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS A COULD RESULT IN THE
VIOLATION OF THE SIXTEEN OF
EXISTING STATUTE WHICH WAS
INTENDED TO LIMIT ANNUAL
INCREASES -- ON THE PROGRAM TO
FIVE PERCENT THE WATER BOARD
ESTIMATES THE BILL REQUIRE UP
TO THIRTEEN MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER ACCOUNT
TO FUND LOCAL PRIVACY GRANTS
FOR ALL PARTICIPATING AGENCIES
AS WELL AS A HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION A BEFORE --
TO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE A. B.
SEVEN SIXTY TWO ON FISH
SHELLFISH HEALTH ADVISORIES
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THIS BILL
REQUIRES THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF THE BOARD TO DETERMINE
WHETHER THE LEGISLATURE HAS
APPROPRIATED SUFFICIENT FUNDS
IN THE ANNUAL BUDGET ACT A
TO COVER LOCAL AGENCIES COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DUTIES
IMPOSED BY THIS BILL AND BY
MAKING LOCAL DUTIES CONTINGENT
UPON THIS APPROPRIATION THIS
BILL CREATES UNKNOWN COST
PRESSURES ON STATE FUNDS
INCLUDING THE GENERAL FUND --
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE
IN THE STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD ESTIMATE THE
COST OF THIS BILL TO BE MINOR
OBSERVABLE THAT OBJECTION
AB SEVEN SIXTY TWO WILL GO
THE SUSPENSE AB EIGHT THIRTY
FOUR SAFE RECREATIONAL WATER
USE THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT WILL
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL ONGOING
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT AND THE WASTE DISCHARGE
PERMIT FUND FEE INCREASES THE
WATER BOARD ESTIMATES BILL WOULD
RESULT IN ANNUAL COSTS FROM THE
WASTE DISCHARGE PERMIT FUND OF
ONE MILLION DOLLARS INCLUDING
ONE TIME COST OF A HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
HERMAN EFFICIENT WILDLIFE
ESTIMATES THE RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE LASTLY
WE NOTE UNCERTAINTY WITH THESE
ESTIMATES GIVEN THE WATER BOARD
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE CURRENTLY PARTICIPATE
IN OTHER SIMILAR PROGRAMS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
THREE FOUR WATER SUSPENSE --
RIGHT YES
AND THEN AB ELEVEN SEVENTY SIX
CEMEX THE SEVENTY EIGHT I'M
SORRY ELEVEN SEVENTY EIGHT I
HAD A MYSELF AB ELEVEN SEVENTY
EIGHT SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INDICATES COSTS OF TWO HUNDRED
TWELVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND THREE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER ADDITIONALLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
REPORTS NO FISCAL IMPACT
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN
SEVENTY EIGHT WILL GO TO CSUS
FENCE MOVING ON TO MISTER MEDINA
IS TO BILLS AB THREE THREE ONE
-- PEOPLE INSTRUCTIONS SUPPORT
THIS IS A PARTIAL WAS TRAVELING
WITH THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT
MARIO GUERRERO WITH A
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
STRONG SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS IT WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND A
REIMBURSABLE STATE COSTS IN THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
THAT OBJECTION AB THREE THREE
ONE WITH OUR SUSPENSE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX STUDENT
TUITION RECOVERY FUND SUPPORT
MARIO GUERRERO ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATIONS
TALKSPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS A NOT WITHSTANDING
THE MERITS OF THIS BILLS EFFORTS
TO PROVIDE RELIEF TO STUDENTS
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL
BECAUSE THE PROPOSED DEFINITION
OF ECONOMIC LOSS IS TOO
BROAD AND MAY UNINTENTIONALLY
BANKRUPT THE -- STUDENT
TUITION RECOVERY FUND AND OR
REQUIRE HIGHER ASSESSMENTS
ON STUDENTS STATEWIDE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX WE GOT A SUSPENSE
ECONOMIST EGGMAN AB THREE
THREE THREE WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTION SEARCH SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
ASIANS ESTIMATES COSTS OF SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTEEN THOUSAND
INITIALLY AND SIX ARE EIGHTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
FROM THE LABOR ENFORCEMENT AND
COMPLIANCE FUND FOR ADDITIONAL
STAFF THAT OBJECTION
AB THREE THREE THREE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB SEVEN EIGHTEEN
DEPENDENT CHILDREN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS A RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
THE DEPARTMENT EXCUSE ME
THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES ESTIMATES OF COSTS
OF A HUNDRED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS NINETY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY THAT OBJECTION
AB SEVENTY TEAM GOING TO
SPEND SAY BE FIFTEEN EIGHTY
THREE HOW RECYCLING SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE WE ESTIMATE
AN EXTENSION OF THE SALES TAX
EXEMPTION PROGRAM WOULD RESULT
IN GENERAL FROM LOS POINT TWO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND EIGHT
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS --
EACH YEAR THEREAFTER INCLUDING
THE REQUIRED BACK FILL FROM THE
GENERAL FUND TO LOCAL REVENUE
FUND OF THREE POINT SEVEN TWO
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SEVEN
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS EACH
YEAR THERE AFTER THE DEPARTMENT
OF RESOURCES RECYCLING IN
RECOVERY ESTIMATES COST OF
THREE HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THE INTEGRATED WASTE
MANAGEMENT ACCOUNT INITIALLY
AND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
THAT COMPLETES OUR THIRD PAGE
OF SEVEN A. B. THREE FORTY
IRWIN AND WE'RE MOVING ON THE
MEASURE WHEN SPILLS FIREARMS
IS THERE ARE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT COULD RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY NINETEEN THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES COST
RANGING FROM FOUR HUNDRED
SEVENTY NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND SIX HUNDRED
EIGHTY TWO THOUSAND TO ONE POINT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AN ON GOING THE BILL COULD
RESULT ADDITIONALLY AN UNKNOWN
BUT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT NON
REIMBURSABLE ON GOING COSTS TO
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES
THAT OBJECTION AB THREE
FORTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO HEALTH
DATA -- THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES LABOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT AGENCY
THE DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
EACH ESTIMATE COSTS IN THE
LOW TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS EACH THAT OBJECTION
AB ELEVEN TWENTY TWO WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE A. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE AND DISABLED
VETERANS COMMITTEE BILL SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE A STATE
ENTITIES AWARDING CONTRACTS
TO PRIME PRIME CONTRACTORS
LISTING THE SUBCONTRACTORS
WILL HAVE INCREASED BUT UNKNOWN
AND LIKELY AT SEVERAL COSTS
AS A RESULT OF THIS BILL THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
ESTIMATES IT WILL INCUR MINOR
OBSERVABLE COST UPDATE THEIR
MANUAL AS WELL AS ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL COST OF ONE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO REVIEW THE ACCURACY
AND COMPLETENESS OF RECORDS
PROVIDED BY THESE CONTRACTORS
THAT OBJECTION A. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY FIVE A LOT OF SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON MR DAILY AB THREE FIVE
FIVE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS
BOARD SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS A RESULT IN
ON BUDGET ON GOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS BY REQUIRING THE
PUBLIC EMPLOYEE RELATIONS BOARD
TO RESOLVE ADDITIONAL UNFAIR
PRACTICE CHARGES IN LABOR
DISPUTES THAT OBJECTION
AB THREE FIVE FIVE AGO THE
SUSPENSE AB SEVENTEEN THIRTY SIX
REQUIREMENTS SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT MAY
RESULT IN ON BUDGET COSTS TO
THE STATE IN EXCESS OF FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND MAY NOT IMPROVE THE
TIMELINESS WITH WHICH APPARENTLY
LEADERS AND THEIR LISTED
SUBCONTRACTORS ARE NOTIFIED
BY LOCAL GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB SEVENTEEN SEVENTY NINE
YOUR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
GIVE ME A MISTER CHAIRMAN HOLY
MEASURE BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF ALCOHOL AND DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES IN OPPOSITION
WE BELIEVE THAT THE BILL CREATES
A UNNECESSARY AND DUPLICATIVE
BUREAUCRACY FOR WORK THAT IS
ALREADY BEING DONE AT THE COUNTY
LEVEL THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT GENERAL
FUND COSTS TO ADMINISTER THE
NEW REQUIREMENTS AND FUND
COUNTY ACTIVITIES PURSUANT
TO PROPOSITION THIRTY
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE TWO POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWO MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY NINE WITH A SUSPENSE A.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY MISTER LACK
THESE BILLS CALIFORNIA CANNABIS
RESEARCH PROGRAM SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE FOR NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN TWENTY
WE'RE GOING TO SUSPEND SAVE
I'M SORRY FOR TWENTY ACTED THAT
AB FOR TWENTY WITH THE SUSPENSE
AB THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE MISTER
LACKEY ON TRANSIT SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WERE
NEUTRAL ON ON THIS MEASURE
-- HOWEVER WE DO NOT CONCERNS
SURROUNDING THE COST PRESSURES
THIS BILL MAY CREATE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE TRANSPORTATION
AGENCY ESTIMATES THE BILL
RESULT IN ONE TIME COSTS BETWEEN
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH
WOULD ALSO INCLUDE ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ISSUE
GUIDELINES FOR THE STATEWIDE
PROGRAM THAT OBJECTION A.
B. THIRTEEN FIFTY ONE WITH
OTHER SUSPECTS MOVING TO MISTER
MAIENSCHEIN SB FOUR TWENTY SIX
IN HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES
THERE ARE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE BASED ON TWENTY EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN DATA WE ESTIMATE THE
BILL RESULTS IN INCREASED IN
HOME SUPPORTIVE SERVICES BENEFIT
AND COUNTY ADMINISTRATION
COSTS OF UP TO TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY TWO POINT TWO MILLION
OF WHICH IS GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND FIVE
HUNDRED SEVENTY TWO POINT FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY THREE POINT FOUR MILLION
WHICH IS GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL REQUIRES MODIFICATIONS
TO THE CASE MANAGEMENT
INFORMATION IMPERILING SYSTEM
WHICH IS ESTIMATED REQUIRE
ONE TIME FUNDING OF A ONE
MILLION DOLLARS FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FOR TWENTY
SIX GO TO SUSPENSE
AB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR --
RESOURCE FAMILIES SERVICES
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE HAS THE ADDITIONAL
WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BILL CREATES NEW GENERAL FUND
COSTS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL CREATES A GENERAL FUND
COSTS FOR SURE OF AT LEAST FOUR
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
OVER TWO YEARS TO FIND FIVE
COUNTIES TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROPOSED PILOT PROGRAM WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVEN THIRTY FOUR
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE JUVENILE DEPENDENCY
CASELOADS SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
INDICATES THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL IS ESTIMATED TO BE
AT LEAST SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
ONE TIME TO CONTRACT WITH A
THIRD PARTY RESEARCH INSTITUTE
TO DEVELOP THE APPROPRIATE
CASE OF STANDARDS STANDARDS FOR
JUDGES AT OBJECTION AB EIGHT
FIFTY NINE WITH -- SUSPENSE AB
NINE SIXTY CAL WORKS HOMELESS
ASSISTANCE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S
CURRENT FISCAL PLAN AND THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN
ALREADY INCLUDES ONE BILLION
ONE BILLION DOLLARS DRIVEN
AND MEDICAID HOMELESSNESS
THAT OBJECTION A. B. NINE SIXTY
ONE A SUSPENSE A. B. TWELVE
FORTY NINE ON HEALTH CARE
SERVICE PLAN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE TO THE EXTENT STATE
ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS ARE NOT
RECOVERED FROM PILOT SPONSORS
THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE MANAGE
CARE FUND COSTS BEYOND WHAT WAS
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S FISCAL
PLAN WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWELVE FORTY NINE WE GOT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ANIMIST CERVANTES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY LOANS
AB FOR SIXTY THREE SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT COULD CREATE A STATE
REIMBURSABLE MANDATE WITH ON
GOING REIMBURSABLE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
COSTS UP TO SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY THOUSAND DOLLARS WITHOUT
OBJECTION A BEFORE SIXTY THREE
WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE AB SEVEN
TEN CERVANTES ON EDUCATION
COST OF ATTENDANCE SUPPORT
THIS IS PART OF A START WITH
THE UC STUDENT ASSOCIATION WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AS THE
UCC IS YOU END CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CURRENTLY
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON THEIR
RESPECTIVE WEBSITES SIMILAR
TO THAT REQUIRED BY THIS BILL
THE UCC ISSUE EN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ESTIMATE
MINOR GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS MEASURE
THAT OBJECTION AB SEVEN TEN
WE'RE GONNA SUSPENSE MOVING
TO PASS SALAS MENTAL HEALTH
-- OLDER ADULTS AB FOR EIGHTY
S. THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT IMPOSES
COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT COMMITS
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES THAT
STATE DIRECTED FUNDS AND IS
DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING METHODS
AND EFFORTS CONCERNING MENTAL
HEALTH IN OLDER ADULTS ACCORDING
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES THIS BILL RESULTS
AND COST OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE SEVEN
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB FOR EIGHTY
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE A. B.
FIVE NINETY FOUR -- AGAIN
ON ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULTS IN
ON BUDGET GENERAL FUND COSTS
OF THREE HUNDRED THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND A
DUPLICATE AND POSSIBLY RESULT IN
CONFLICTING GUIDANCE REGARDING
THE WORK BEING PERFORMED BY
THE FUTURE OF WORK COMMISSION
THAT OBJECTION A. B. FIVE NINETY
FOUR WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVING
TO MISTER GLORIA A BEFORE NINETY
THREE TEACHERS AND ELDERS
LGBT Q. PEOPLE TRAINING
OPPOSITION FINANCE YES
WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS THE TRAINING REQUIRED BY
THIS BILL IS DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING TEACHER PREPARATION
AND LOCAL EDUCATIONAL AGENCY
INITIATIVES ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL COULD CREATE A REIMBURSABLE
STATE MANDATE IN THE TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND BY
REQUIRING AT LEAST PROVIDE
BY IN A BIENNIAL TRAINING TO
APPLICABLE CERTIFICATED STAFF
ON SCHOOL SITE AND COMMUNITY
RESOURCES AND STRATEGIES FOR THE
CURRENT SUPPORT OF THESE PEOPLE
CAPTION A BEFORE NINETY
THREE WATER SUSPENSE A. B.
NINE THIRTY CSU EXECUTIVE
COMPENSATION SUPPORT
GOOD AFTERNOON MARIO GUERRERO
ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION WE ARE
THE -- SPONSOR OF THE BILL
AND WE JUST NOTE THAT --
THIS IS BASIC -- -- BUDGETARY
-- -- ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY FOR ANY PUBLIC
AGENCY WE BELIEVE -- WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S THE CASE HERE AND
ALSO -- THE CAMPUSES HAVE
STATED IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY THAT
THEY -- REPORT A LOT OF THIS
INFORMATION THEY CERTAINLY HAVE
BUDGETARY STAFF SO WE BELIEVE
THAT THE COST TO THE SHOULD BE
-- SOMEWHAT MINIMAL AND ADORABLE
-- IT AGAIN JUST IN TERMS OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU SURE OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AS IT CREATES
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS IN
THE RANGE OF ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO TWO MILLION
DOLLARS AND ONE POINT AND
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND COST OF
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL RESTRICTS
THE ABILITY OF OF THE CSU BOARD
OF TRUSTEES WHICH IS CHARGED
WITH GOVERNING THE UNIVERSITY TO
DETERMINE THE MOST APPROPRIATE
WAYS TO MANAGE OPERATIONS
CONSISTENT WITH STICKLES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB NINE THIRTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE -- MOVING
ON THE A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR PUBLIC RECORDS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION ONLY MEASUREMENT
HAVE TO THE CITY OF WEST
HOLLYWOOD IN OPPOSITION TO THE
INCREASED COST IT WILL CAUSE
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT THANK YOU
FINANCE YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS IT WILL RESULT IN
UNKNOWN BUT INCREASE IN ONGOING
COSTS TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO THE WORKLOAD
INCREASES THAT ARE LIKELY TO
MATERIALIZE AS A RESULT OF
RETAINING ON PERTINENT EMAILS
CRITICALLY FOR LESS SPECIFIC A
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACTS
ACT REQUESTS -- AND WHILE
WE'RE UNABLE TO DETERMINE
WITH CERTAINTY IT WHAT THE
STATE WHAT IMPACT WILL BE A
WE BELIEVE IT COULD BE IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EACH YEAR
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOUR WE'RE GOING TO
SUSPENSE AB TWELVE THIRTY
TWO PORTABLE HOUSING SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE YES WE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS IT
IMPOSES ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD
REQUIREMENTS ON THE DEPARTMENT
OF COMMUNITY SERVICES AND
DEVELOPMENT THAT LIKELY
CANNOT BE ABSORBED WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENTS ADMINISTRATION
BUDGET OF FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ONE TIME
A GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
FUNDED TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
WITHOUT OBJECTION A. B. TWELVE
THIRTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MR MATHIS HAS ONE BILL AB
FIVE FIFTEEN SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE YES WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT MAY RESULT IN
REDUCED GENERAL FUND REVENUES
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AND COULD
MAKE IT MORE DIFFICULT FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES TO COLLECT OVERPAYMENTS
FROM PROVIDERS THAT INJECTION
AB FIVE FIFTEEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB FIVE SIXTEEN WERE
NOW MOVING TO MISTER CHIU --
AB FIVE SIXTEEN --
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT MAY RESULT IN
REIMBURSABLE STATE MANDATED
COSTS AS WELL AS SIGNIFICANT BUT
UNKNOWN COST TO THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL THAT OBJECTION
AB FIVE SIXTEEN GO TO SUSPENSE
AB EIGHT FIFTY SEVEN MIL
ON PUBLIC BANKS SUPPORT
COME ON UP
FOLLOWED BY OPPOSITION
CITY RIVER LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEE CHAIR PACIFIC PART OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL FOR ABOUT FIFTY YEARS SOME
THANK YOU THE OPPOSITION
FINANCE IF THIS IS OVERSEE
ANTICIPATES A RANGE OF COSTS
FROM TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO TWO POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
AND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND I'M GOING
TO ISSUE REGULATIONS AND TO
SUPPORT THE OVERSIGHT OF PUBLIC
BANKS TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL
THAT OBJECTION AB EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPECTS
-- MOVIE ON THE A. B. THIRTEEN
FORTY PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION IS OUR PORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT COST TO THE BUREAU
FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION AND MAY REQUIRE A FEE
INCREASE WHICH COULD ULTIMATELY
BE PASSED ON TO STUDENTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
ESTIMATES THE BUREAU WILL INCUR
COSTS OF SIX HUNDRED THIRTEEN
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE
AND FIVE HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
ADDITIONALLY THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT INDICATES
COSTS OF FIFTEEN HUNDRED DOLLARS
ANNUALLY TO RIDE WAGE RECORDS
EACH YEAR THAT
OBJECTION A. B. THIRTEEN FORTY
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB SEVENTEEN
FIFTY ONE ON WATER AND SEWER
SYSTEMS SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE I WE'RE NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT ALIGNS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS
TO CONSOLIDATE FEELING WATER
SYSTEMS TO PROVIDE SAFE DRINKING
WATER TO CALIFORNIANS BUT NOT
A CONCERN THAT THE BILL PLACES
NEW STATUTORY RESTRICTIONS ON
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
WHICH MAY REQUIRE THE CPUC
TO RE PRIORITIZE AND REDIRECT
EXISTING STAFF RESOURCES TO
WATER SYSTEM CONSOLIDATION
WORKLOAD THAT OBJECTION
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY ONE WITHOUT
A SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
BERMAN'S BILLS AB FIVE TWENTY
ONE ON PHYSICIANS AND FIREARMS
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL
INDICATES THIS BILL MAY RESULT
IN MINOR AN OBSERVABLE COSTS
TO THE TRIAL COURT'S OBJECTION
AB FIVE TWENTY ONE WE'RE GONNA
SUSPENSE AB SIX OH TWO DIGITAL
DEPICTION OF AN INDIVIDUAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
APOLOGIZE -- THE FISCAL IT FOR
AB SIX OR TWO IS DID YOU SHOW
COUNSEL AND HITS THE BILL MAY
RESULT IN MY ARMS ARE COURTS
THE PROBLEM WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SIX OH TWO OTHER SUSPECTS
SB SIX TWO THREE ELECTIONS
BALLOT DESIGN IS HER
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS REQUIRES THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO CREATE
AN ADVISORY COMMITTEE WHICH
WILL REQUIRE ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND RESOURCES NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
THAT OBJECTION AB SIX TWENTY
THREE WITH OTHER SUSPECTS AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY TWO SCHOOL
BASED HEALTH PROGRAMS AS THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE IS
WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
IS IS AS IT IS TO PUT IT OF
OF EFFORTS UNDERWAY AT THE
STATE LEVEL INCLUDING THE
FORMATION OF AN INTERAGENCY
WORK GROUP CREATED AS PART OF
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION AND INDICATES COSTS
OF APPROXIMATELY SIX HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO ESTABLISH THE OFFICE AND MEET
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL
THAT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY TWO WILL GO TWO SUSPECTS
A. B. THIRTEEN FORTY ONE
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE THE RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
GENERAL FUND COSTS THAT ARE
INCONSISTENT WITH THE CURRENT
BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES COST OF TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
FIVE HUNDRED TWELVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVING TO THIS PETRIE-NORRIS
AB FIVE TWENTY SIX MEDI CAL
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES
LOCAL ASSISTANCE COSTS OF
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY POINT THREE
MILLION DOLLARS NINE POINT EIGHT
NINE POINT EIGHT MILLION OF
WHICH ARE GENERAL FUND IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION
AND SIXTEEN POINT ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO SEVEN POINT SIX
MILLION WHICH ARE GENERAL
FUND EACH YEAR THERE AFTER
ADDITIONALLY A DIDN'T THE
MINISTRY OF COSTS INCLUDING
SYSTEM CHANGE COSTS FOR
HEALTHCARE SERVICES IS ESTIMATED
TO BE APPROXIMATELY FIVE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS TWO POINT
SIX MILLION OF WHICH IS GENERAL
FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR FROM
THE PLANTATION AND TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER IN ORDER TO
IMPLEMENT THE REQUIRED
UPGRADES TO THE WITH PROGRAMS
NEW MANAGEMENT INFORMATION
SYSTEM THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH ESTIMATES COST
RANGING FROM FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ONE MILLION
DOLLARS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIVE TWENTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE A. B. NINE ONE NINE
ON ALCOHOL AND DRUG ABUSE
RECOVERY SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THIS BILL RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
TO THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES A SPECIFICALLY
THE DEPARTMENT ESTIMATES IT
WILL NEED A SEVEN FULL TIME
ONGOING POSITIONS AT A COST OF
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB NINE NINETEEN
WILL GO TO SUSPEND SAY ME
NINE TWENTY ON SUBSTANCE USE
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDER SERVICES
SUPPORT MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
MEASURE OUR BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ALCOHOL DRUG
PROGRAM EXECUTIVES IN SUPPORT
WE THINK IT'S WELL WORTH THE
INVESTMENT TO BRING THE CODE
UP TO STANDARD UP TO CURRENT
CURRENT PRACTICE THANK YOU
OPPOSITION FINANCE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
IT IMPOSES COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT AND IS DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING STAKEHOLDER AN ADVISORY
WORKGROUPS RELATED TO THIS ISSUE
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE LOW
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
THAT OBJECTION AB NINE TWENTY
WITH OTHER SUSPECTS A. B.
NINE THIRTY THREE WATERSHED
PROTECTION SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURES IT CREATES FUTURE
STATE COST PRESSURES DOES
NOT IDENTIFY A SPECIFIC FUND
FORCE AND CODIFIES AN EXISTING
PROGRAM WHICH WILL LIMIT
THE ADMINISTRATION'S FUTURE
FLEXIBILITY AND OPERATING
THIS PROGRAM THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSERVATION ESTIMATES COST
OF FOUR HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND TWO HUNDRED THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
THAT OBJECTION AB NINE THIRTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB NINE SIXTY THREE STUDENT
CIVIC INVOLVING COMMENT SIR
SUPPORT QUESTIONS ARE THE UC
STUDENT ASSOCIATION THIS IS
A BE LOOK AT THAT WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT AND -- WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S VERY SMALL AMOUNTS
TO BUDGETARY -- COSTS THAT
ARE ASSOCIATED WITH IT WITH
IMMENSE AMOUNTS OF OUTCOME
IN TERMS OF SUPPORTING OUR --
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND EDUCATION
SO WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
I'M WITH THE RESERVE
MILLION VEGETABLES IN FULL
SUPPORT ANY OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AS IT LIKELY
CREATES A REIMBURSABLE STATE
MANDATE WITH ONGOING PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT GENERAL FUND
COST RANGING FROM ONE MILLION
DOLLARS TO TWO MILLION DOLLARS
FOR EVERY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
TO IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE ONE TIME GENERAL
FUND COSTS IN THE RANGE OF
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO ONE MILLION DOLLARS FOR C.
CSU CAMPUSES TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS MEASURE
ALAN JACKSON A. B. NINE SIXTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB ELEVEN TWENTY EIGHT
ELDERLY CARE THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WHERE
POSES MEASURE AS IT SHIFTS
LICENSING WORKLOAD COSTS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH LICENSING FEE REVENUES
TO THE GENERAL FUND AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES CURRENTLY LACKS THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
SLOW OF EXPERTISE IN OVERSEEING
PHYSICAL FACILITIES WHICH
RESULTS IN HIGHER STATE COSTS
FOR THE SAME OVERSIGHT WORKLOAD
THE BILL WILL RESULT IN COSTS
OF APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND WHICH IS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ONE POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS OF WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AN ON GOING
THAT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN TWENTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE THAT
COMPLETES PAGE FOR MOVING ON TO
MISTER LOW AB FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES SUPPORT
SATELLITE COOPER ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO
IN SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE SECURES
FUND CANNOT SUSTAIN THE
ESTIMATED EXPENDITURES NEEDED
TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL WHICH
RESULTS IN A GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURE IN ADDITION THE JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY ONE DEADLINE
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
ADOPT THE REGULATIONS REQUIRED
BY THIS BILL IS PROBLEMATIC AND
WILL LIKELY NOT BE MET BECAUSE
THE DEPARTMENT IS CURRENTLY
IN THE PROCESS OF ADOPTING
OTHER CURES RELATED REGULATIONS
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
INDICATES COST OF EIGHT HUNDRED
SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE AND ON GOING
THAT OBJECTION AB FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
A. B. FOURTEEN FIFTY ONE
PETITION CIRCULATORS AIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT MAY CREATE
AN ELECTION RELATED MANDATE
REQUIRING ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
TO DETERMINE WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF SIGNATURES GATHERED OR
SUBMITTED BY PERSONS WHO DO NOT
RECEIVE COMPENSATION FOR OTHER
SIGNATURES ADDITIONALLY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE ESTIMATES
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ONE TIME GENERAL FUND TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS CONSISTENT WITH
THE PROVISIONS OF THIS MEASURE
LASTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES GENERAL FUND COSTS
OF SIX HUNDRED TWENTY NINE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY APPROXIMATELY
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
NINE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
TWENTY TWO AND SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY ONE WILL GO THROUGH
SUSPENSE AB FIFTEEN OH ONE
FORENSIC BALLISTIC AND FIREARM
PROCEDURES AS THEIR SUPPORT
PROPOSITION SIR FIVE
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
NOT INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT IN ADDITION
IT CREATES A POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT STATE REIMBURSABLE
MANDATE ON LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES WITHOUT OBJECTION
A. B. FIFTEEN A ONE VOTER
SUSPENSE A. B. FIFTEEN NINETEEN
ON HEALING ARTS SUPPORT
THE CHAIRMAN GARY COOPER
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION ORAL AND
MAXILLOFACIAL SURGEONS AND WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB FIFTY NINE
OPPOSITION FINANCE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS INDICATES
THE DENTAL BOARD WOULD INCUR
MYRON OBSERVABLE COST UPDATE
REGULATIONS AND ENFORCEMENT
CODES IN THE SYSTEM BUT WOULD
INCUR ADDITIONAL COSTS OF TWO
HUNDRED NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
A TO HIRE ITS OWN ATTORNEY
THAT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
NINETEEN WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
A. B. FIFTEEN TWENTY ON
COURT REPORTERS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS FOR
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE THAT
OBJECTION MAYBE FIFTEEN TWENTY
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE IN FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
TWENTY TWO ON THIS MEASURE THAT
OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN TWENTY
ONE OF THE OTHER SUSPECTS AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO -- ENGINEERS
AND LAND SURVEYORS A GEOLOGIST
SUPPORT PROPOSITION FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
IS INDICATED THE BILL WILL
NOT CREATE ANY SIGNIFICANT
FISCAL IMPACTS BUT OBJECTION AB
FIFTEEN TWENTY TWO WILL GO THE
SUSPENSE AB FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE
A STATE ATHLETIC COMMISSION
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
DOES NOT EXPECT ANY FISCAL
IMPACT AS A RESULT OF EXTENDING
THE COMMISSION'S OPERATION
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
TWENTY THREE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE
MOVIE ON THE MISSILE MON
AB FIVE FORTY CAL GRANT THE
SERVICE INCENTIVE GRANTS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
THIS PROGRAM HAS ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISH -- BY SB SEVENTY
SEVEN AND HAS BEEN FUNDED TO
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT
THAT OBJECTION AB FIVE
FORTY WITHOUT THE SUSPENSE
EIGHTY EIGHT FORTY TWO CHILD
NUTRITION SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE FILE THAT OBJECTION
AB FORTY EIGHT FOR TWO
OTHER SUSPECTS AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN IS LOW ON OIL AND GAS
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FILE IS A
NEUTRAL ON THIS MEASURE THAT
OBJECTION AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN
WE'LL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
TO MISTER FOR -- EIGHTY FIVE
FIVE ZERO ON VETERANS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS
AFFAIRS INDICATES THE BILL MAY
RESULT IN MINOR UNKNOWN ACOSTA
VETERANS CHOOSE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS PROGRAM VERSUS RECITING
A VETERANS HOME OF CALIFORNIA
AND AT THE TIME AT THE TIME OF
THIS ANALYSIS THE FULL IN FISCAL
IMPACT CANNOT BE DETERMINED
WITHOUT MORE OPERATIONAL DETAILS
ON HOW THE PROGRAM WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED IN CALIFORNIA
HI LESLIE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE ESTIMATES
THE COST IN THE RANGE OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO THREE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO COMPLETE THE AUDIT
REQUESTED IN THE BILL THAT
OBJECTION AB FIVE FIVE ZERO
GO TO SUSPENSE AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO MANTECA REDEVELOPMENT
ASSET DISPOSAL THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE HAS
A CIRCUMVENTS CURRENT STATUTE
AND ALLOWS THE MENTAL PROCESSES
SUCCESSOR AGENCY TO CELEBRATE
DEVELOPMENT PROPERTY FOR AN
AMOUNT LESS THAN FAIR MARKET
VALUE -- WE ANTICIPATE THAT
THE PROPERTY WAS SOLD FOR LESS
THAN FAIR MARKET VALUE THE ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND COST EXPOSURE
WOULD BE BETWEEN ZERO AND
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS DEPENDING ON THE SELL
PRICE TRANSACTION AB SEVENTEEN
THIRTY TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB FIVE SEVEN WANT WERE MOVING
MISTER MULLINS BILLS AB FIVE
SEVEN ONE ON POLITICAL REFORM
ACT AS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT GENERAL FUND COSTS
TO THE STATE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION ESTIMATES
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND AND SEVENTY
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO IMPLEMENT
AND ENFORCE THIS MEASURE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIVE
SEVENTY ONE WITH OTHER SUSPENSE
AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE MULLIN
CLIMATE ADAPTATION STRATEGIES
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURES INCREASE ON GOING
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY ESTIMATES OF COSTS OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING TO CREATE AN UPDATE THE
STRATEGIC RESILIENCY FRAMEWORK
ADDITIONALLY THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AUTHORITY ESTIMATES A NINETY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
PROPOSITION ONE A FUNDS WILL BE
NEEDED FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES ESTIMATES
THAT TWO HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL FUND
COSTS WILL BE NEEDED WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MOVING TO
MISTER BLOOM A. B. FIVE NINETY
EIGHT ON HEARING AIDS SUPPORT
KATHLEEN SORIANO WITH THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT IS THERE
OPPOSITION SIR FIVE
YES WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
CURRENT FISCAL PLAN DID MANAGE
HEALTHCARE ESTIMATES COSTS
OF TWO HUNDRED EIGHT THAT TWO
HUNDRED AND EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER ADDITIONALLY
THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH BENEFITS
REVIEW PROGRAM ESTIMATES GENERAL
FUND COST OF TWO POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO THREE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
TO COVER THIS BENEFIT FOR SMALL
GROUP AND INDIVIDUAL AND RELEASE
AND COVERED CALIFORNIA PLANS
THAT OBJECTION AB FIVE
NINETY EIGHT WITHOUT A
SUSPENSE A. B. FIFTEEN ELEVEN
ON COASTAL RESOURCES SUPPORT
OPPOSITION IT'S GONNA TAKE YOU
A CHAIR MEMBERS -- I'M WALTER
LANOLIN TEAR WITH VIOLENCE LAND
TRUST WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AS
WRITTEN BECAUSE WE BELIEVE IT
DIE WILL FUNDAMENTALLY UNDERMINE
THE FISCAL JUSTIFICATION
FOR TREATING THIS COMMISSION
THE FIRST PLACE MOST NOTABLY
AFTER THIRTY ONE YEARS THIS
COMMISSION COULD FOR THE FIRST
TIME LOSE ITS LOCAL STAFF IT'S
A LOCALLY BASED STATE AGENCY
WHEN THIS COMMISSION WAS CREATED
OR WHAT BUT IT'S PURPOSES OF
THE PROJECT WAS CREATED IN THE
COMMISSION WAS FORMALIZED NEW
THOUSAND TWO IT WAS VERY CLEAR
THAT A PURPOSE WAS TO HAVE
LOCALLY BASED AFTER AND LOCAL
SCIENTIFIC WORK IN THE IN THE
SENATE WATERSHED -- BUT WHILE
THE COSTA REMOTE STAFF MAY NOT
BE GREATER THAN LOCAL STAFF THE
BENEFIT TO THE PUBLIC BUT PLAN
IT WOULD IT WOULD UNDERMINE
THE PURPOSE OF THE AGENCY SO WE
BELIEVE THAT'S A CLEAR FISCAL
IMPACT ANOTHER AT THE SCHOOL
IMPACT IS THAT THERE ABOUT SIX
OR THOUSAND DOLLARS ANNUALLY
A FEDERAL FUNDS THAT WERE
USED PREVIOUSLY BY THE STATE
TO FUND THIS COMMISSION AUG
THE REGULATIONS TO REQUIRES THAT
THE COMMISSION HAS CONTROL OVER
THOSE FUNDS AND COULD USE THOSE
FUNDS TO STOP THIS COMMISSION
-- BUT IN TWO THOUSAND SIX THERE
IS AGREEMENT WITH A PRIVATE
FOUNDATION TO GIVE THE FUNDS TO
THE FOUNDATION FOR THE EXPRESS
PURPOSE OF HIRING STAFF PEOPLE
FOR THE COMMISSION AND THAT
AGREEMENT IS UNILATERALLY BROKEN
BY THE FOUNDATION WHICH BY
THE WAY IS THE FISCAL SPONSOR
THIS AGENCY VERY CONCERNED THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO TRY
TO LOCK THAT IN IS AN ACCEPTED
-- FISCAL IMPACT EVEN THOUGH
IT'S NOT ADDRESS IN THE ANALYSIS
AND THEN THAT'S GONNA SEGUE
INTO THE THE -- LEGAL EXPOSURE
UNFORTUNATELY OUR RELATIONS
ISLAMABAD JURISTS MOTIVATION
WE SEE THIS MISSION THREE TIMES
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN BACK
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN THIS
COMMITTEE APPROPRIATED ABOUT A
QUARTER MILLION DOLLARS TOWARD
ATTORNEY WHICH WAS PUBLIC
FUNDS I WAS THAT HAPPY ABOUT
THAT TOM AND AT THAT TIME THIS
COMMITTEE ASKED FOR THERE TO
BE GREATER CLARITY BETWEEN
THE FOUNDATION THE COMMISSION
SENATOR BATES YOU SPECIFICALLY
COMMENTED ON THE DISTINCTION
BETWEEN THE PRIVATE COMMISSION
THE PUBLIC OUTSIDE THE PUBLIC
THE COMMISSION A PRIVATE
FOUNDATION WITHIN ANOTHER
LAWSUIT THAT REQUIRE INCLUSION
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO SEE AN ANALYSIS
THAT ADDRESSES ON THESE FISCAL
IMPACTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FINANCE IS WE DON'T HAVE A
POSITION ON THIS BILL THAT WOULD
KNOW THAT THE -- BOARD INDICATES
-- THEY WOULD HAVE MINOR MINOR
REDUCTION IN COSTS AS THEIR
ABSORB IS PART OF THE OTHER
STAFF DUTIES THE CONSERVANCY
ESTIMATES THE BILL WILL GENERATE
ANNUAL SUPPORT STAFF COST
RANGING FROM THREE HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND DOLLARS TO SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES TO THE COMMISSION
-- ADDITIONALLY RESTRICTIONS
ON THE USE OF THE GENERAL
OBLIGATION BONDS WHICH SERVES
THE CONSERVANCY'S PRIMARY FUND
SOURCE WOULD PROHIBIT THEIR USE
FOR PROVIDING ADMINISTRATIVE
SERVICES TO THE COMMISSION THE
ENVIRONMENTAL LICENSE PLATE
FUNDS THE SECONDARY SOURCE
OF FUNDS FOR THE CONSERVANCY
IS NOT POSITION TO ABSORB
ADDITIONAL COSTS AND AS A
RESULT THIS BILL WILL LIKELY
RESULT IN GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FIFTEEN ELEVEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISS
CARILLO AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN
FIVE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE OR NEUTRAL ON THIS
MEASURE ACTION AB SIX OH
SEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB SIX
SEVENTY THREE FAIR TO PAY WAGES
IS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE THE RESULT IN
COSTS AND CONSISTENT WITH THE
CURRENT BUDGET AND MAY RESULT IN
DUPLICATE OF PENALTIES ALREADY
APPLIED TO AND PAID WHICH
VIOLATIONS SUBJECTING EMPLOYERS
TO PENALTIES TWICE FOR THE SAME
VIOLATION THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
COSTS OF NINE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ONE
POINT NINE MILLION DOLLARS
INITIALLY AND EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
TO ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY ON GOING
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIX SEVENTY
THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB FORTINO THREE -- GENERAL
ASSISTANCE ELIGIBILITY IS
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS IN
SIGNIFICANT ON GOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S FISCAL
PLAN WELL THE FISCAL IMPACT OF
THIS BILL CANNOT BE ESTIMATED
WITH CERTAINTY IT IS LIKELY
THAT IF ENACTED IT WILL RESULT
IN GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE
LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN THE
FIRST YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION
THE LOW TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THIS BILL ALSO RESULT IN ONE
TIME AUTOMATION COST LIKELY IN
EXCESS OF ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB FORTINO THREE WITH A SUSPENSE
A. B. FOURTEEN SEVENTY EIGHT
-- EMPLOYMENT DISCRIMINATION
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES THE BILL
HAS NO FISCAL IMPACT ON THE
DEPARTMENT TO THE EXTENT THIS
BILL ADDS TO THE TRIAL COURTS
CASELOAD THE COURT BACKLOGS ME
INCREASING COULD CREATE PRESSURE
ON THE GENERAL FUND HOWEVER
UNLESS THIS PARTICULAR CASE
THE BECOME SIGNIFICANT -- IT
IS LIKELY TO BE ABSORBED THAT
OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN SEVENTY
EIGHT ORDER SUSPENSE A. B.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES SUPPORT MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MULLIN FOR
THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
DIRECTIVES WE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORS WE'VE ALSO BEEN AUST
BY LA COUNTY WHO'S ALSO A
CO SPONSOR TO SUPPORTED HERE
TODAY JUST WANT TO MAKE IT
CLEAR THIS IS A POLICY BILL IT
EXTENDS THE THIRTY OF THE LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICER WE DON'T SEE
ANY FISCAL IMPLICATIONS TO THE
STATE THANK YOU OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE A NEUTRON
THIS MEASURE -- AND KELLY
P. ESTIMATES THE COST OF THE
BILL DE MINERS ARE OVAL BUT
WOULD NOT THE CONCERN THAT
BUSINESSES ARE FACILITIES ORDER
TO IMMEDIATELY DISCONTINUE
OPERATIONS MAY SUFFER UNKNOWN
ECONOMIC IMPACTS WHICH COULD
RESULT IN ADDITIONAL IMPACTS
TO ON THEIR LOCAL ECONOMY
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
ON IT WITH OTHER SUSPENSE A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS AIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE WE OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE AS IT WILL RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT ADDITIONAL
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
THE CALIFORNIA CONSERVATION
CORPS -- ESTIMATES SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS
POTENTIALLY IN THE MILLIONS TO
TENS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ON
GOING THAT OBJECTION
AB SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT WILL
GO TO SUSPENSE AB SIXTEEN
NINETY FIVE HEALTH FACILITIES
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
ESTIMATES FISCAL IMPACT BETWEEN
SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AND ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS FROM THE
PUBLIC HEALTH LICENSING AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM FUND IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
AND EACH YEAR THEREAFTER THAT
OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN NINETY
FIVE UP TO JOIN A SPEAKER AB
SIXTEEN NINETY FIVE ABOUT A
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON S. B. R.
A. B. SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
ON IMMIGRATION SUPPORT
I'M NOT SURE THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION
SUPPORT OTHERS IN SUPPORT
THIS RESPONSE IS THE
CHAIR OF THE COALITION FOR
HUMANE IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
ARE PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION CO SPONSOR
THANK YOU MY THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
COSPONSORED THIS IS A PRIORITY
BILL FOR LOS ANGELES COUNTY
THERE'S BEEN INCIDENTS OF
FRAUD IN -- WITH THE COUNTY
DEPARTMENT THAT HAS IDENTIFIED
ABOUT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
AMONG THOSE THAT HAVE REPORTED
IT WE SUSPECT THERE ARE MANY
OTHERS THAT HAVE NOT REPORTED
IT FOR THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OF THOSE WHO
HAVE EXPERIENCED THIS FRAUDULENT
ACTIVITY WE WE SEE THIS THAT
ON AND EVERYTHING NEEDS TO GET
DRESSED THANK YOU OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE'RE NEUTRAL ON
THIS MEASURE BUT NO CONCERNS
THAT IT DOES RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED
IN THE STATE'S FISCAL PLAN
SECRETIVE STATE ESTIMATES
BECAUSE OF TWENTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE DIPLOMAT THE
CHANGES REQUIRED BY THIS BILL
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
JUSTICE ESTIMATES COSTS OF FIVE
HUNDRED NINETY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND SEVEN
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AN ON GOING A WE WOULD KNOW
THAT ANY COSTS THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ARE CONTINGENT
UPON COMPLIANCE RATES WITH
THE NEW LAW AND ANY REQUESTS
FOR ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WILL
BE EVALUATED AS PART OF THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SEVENTEENTH
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MR FRAZIER HAS SO THREE
BILLS START WITH EIGHTY SIX
TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED ELEMENTAL
SERVICES SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS A RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COSTS ABOUT THE LEVEL REFLECTED
IN THE STATE'S CURRENT MULTI
YOUR FISCAL PLAN ASSUMING TEN
SATELLITE OFFICES ARE IDENTIFIED
AND ACTIVATED THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
TO BUILD RESULT IN GENERAL FUND
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY FOUR
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
THREE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE GROWING
BY FIVE PERCENT EACH YEAR
THEREAFTER WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SIX TWENTY SEVEN WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE A. B. SEVEN OH
EIGHT TRAFFIC VIOLATORS SCHOOL
SAYS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES ARE NOT WITHSTANDING
THE MERITS OF THIS BILL WE
OPPOSE BECAUSE IT MAY EXACERBATE
THE PROJECT TO DROP IN THE
MOTOR VEHICLE ACCOUNTS RESERVES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
AWAIT WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO SPECIAL
EDUCATION SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THIS BILL COULD CREATE
ONGOING COST PRESSURES FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES LIKELY
IN THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF DOLLARS PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND TO INCREASE
LOCAL MONITORING EFFORTS
OF NON PUBLIC NONSECTARIAN
SCHOOLS ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL CREATES UNKNOWN BUT
LIKELY SIGNIFICANT LOCAL COST
PRESSURES BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
A NON PUBLIC NONSECTARIAN
SCHOOLS TO TRAIN STAFF IN
EVIDENCE BASED PRACTICES
I WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
ELEVEN SEVENTY TWO WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE WE'RE GOING ON A
MISTER GRAY AB SIX THIRTY
EIGHT SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL BECAUSE IT CREATES
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COSTS -- AND COST PRESSURES NOT
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT THE DEPARTMENT OF
WATER RESOURCES ESTIMATES THAT
APPROXIMATELY SIXTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND WILL BE
NEEDED TO IMPLEMENT THIS BILL
-- AND TO THE EXTENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES
REQUIRED TO MAKE GRANTS
AVAILABLE FOR MITIGATION EFFORTS
THERE WOULD BE ADDITIONAL
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COST
PRESSURES WE WOULD KNOW THAT
THEIR SIGNIFICANT UNCERTAINTY
WITH THESE COST ESTIMATES
AND ANY REQUEST FOR RESOURCES
WOULD BE REVIEWED UNDER THE
ANNUAL BUDGET PROCESS WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIX THIRTY ABLE
GO TO SUSPENSE AB SEVEN SIXTY
THREE MEDI CAL THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURES THAT
RESULTS IN SIGNIFICANT AND
UNKNOWN GENERAL FUND COSTS
THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES ESTIMATES SIGNIFICANT
-- BUT UNKNOWN -- COSTS FOR
COUNTY MENTAL HEALTH PLANS
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
ESTIMATES IT WILL NEED FULL
TIME POSITIONS AT A COST
OF ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
TWO THOUSAND WHICH IS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND FOUR HUNDRED NINETY
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS TO IN
FORTY SIX THOUSAND WHICH IS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWENTY TWO AND THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB SEVEN SIXTY
THREE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE --
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR ON THE
LOTTERY SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE THE LOTTERY
COMMISSION AND THE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE OF BOTH CONDUCTED RECENT
AUDITS OF THE COMMISSION AND
ALREADY TAKING CORRECTIVE
ACTIONS TO REMEDY THE AUDIT
FINDINGS THE LOTTERY COMMISSION
ESTIMATES THE BILL REQUIRE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LOTTERY EDUCATION FUND
EVERY TWO YEARS TO CONDUCT
THE AUDIT THAT OBJECTION
AB FOURTEEN SIXTY FOUR WITHOUT
A SUSPENSE I DID NOT WIN
THE POWER BALL ON SATURDAY
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE I WAS
HOPING I HAD LOTS OF HOPE AND
MARLENA HAD LOTS OF -- PEOPLE
EXACTLY KEEP HOPE ALIVE ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
MISTER GRAYSON AB SIX FIFTY
ONE ON AIR AMBULANCE SERVICES
SAYS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS A CREATE SIGNIFICANT
ONGOING GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT
INCLUDED IN THE ADMINISTRATION
SPENDING PLAN AND INCREASES
RISKS TO THE STATE BUDGET IN
FUTURE YEARS THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ESTIMATES
COSTS OF TWENTY TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS A SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ONGOING ANNUAL COST OF FORTY
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
FOURTEEN POINT FOUR MILLION
OF WHICH ARE GENERAL FUND
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIX FIFTY
ONE WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB NINE
OH SEVEN ON MATH THREATS
SCHOOL PLACES OF WORSHIP
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE THREATENING TO COMMIT
A CRIME WHICH WILL RESULT IN
DEATH OR GREAT BODILY INJURY IS
ALREADY A CRIME A FURTHER THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
CONVICTIONS INCREASING THE
STATE PRISON POPULATION WHICH
IMPACTS THE STATE'S ABILITY
TO MAINTAIN COMPLIANCE WITH
THE FEDERAL COURT ORDER -- TO
REDUCE OUR PRISON OVERCROWDING
TO ONE HUNDRED THIRTY SEVEN
POINT FIVE PERCENT OF DESIGN
CAPACITY ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL COULD RESULT IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION'S CURRENT FISCAL
PLAN THAT OBJECTION AB NINE
OH SEVEN WITH THE SUSPENSE A. B.
TEN TWENTY FIVE ON IRON
HORSE REGIONAL TRAIL FUNDING
-- THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN TEN POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A NOT GOING INTO THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT
FOR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
PURPOSES THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TEN TWENTY
FIVE WILL GO TO SUSPECT AB
ELEVEN SIXTEEN ON FIREFIGHTERS
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ESTIMATES COST OF THREE HUNDRED
FIFTEEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A AND M. ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FORESTRY AND FIRE
PROTECTION INDICATES COSTS OF
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND PER YEAR
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE OTHER POTENTIAL COST TO
THE EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES
AUTHORITY -- OR UNKNOWN AT THE
TIME OF THIS ANALYSIS -- BUT WE
KNOW THAT IT WOULD ONLY IMPACT
SIX TO TEN OF ITS PERSONNEL
THAT OBJECTION AB ONE ONE
ONE SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB ONE ONE ONE SEVEN AND
PEACE OFFICERS -- SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE THE OFFICE
OF EMERGENCY SERVICES ESTIMATES
COST OF TWO HUNDRED NINETY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THIRTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING GENERAL FUND
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE INDICATES
COSTS RELATED TO THIS MEASURE
ARE FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY NINETEEN
TWENTY AND FIVE HUNDRED FORTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS THEREAFTER
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY
PATROL INDICATES IT ALREADY
HAS DISAPPEAR UP YOUR SUPPORT
PROGRAM AND THE REQUIREMENTS
OF THIS BILL MAYBE TWO CLICK IT
OF FINALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
CORRECTIONS AND REHABILITATION
DOES NOT INTERPRET THIS BILL
IS REQUIRED TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM BECAUSE IT ALREADY
OPERATES AN EXISTING PROGRAM
-- HOWEVER WE WOULD NOTE THAT
THIS ALTHOUGH THE BILL MAY
CREATE REDUNDANCY TO THIS THAT
THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE ADDITIONAL GENERAL
FUND COST PRESSURE WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB ONE ONE ONE SEVEN
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE MOVING
TO MISTER EDUARDO GARCIA SB
SIX FIVE SIX OFFICE OF
HEALTHY AND SAFE COMMUNITIES
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE THE RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT AND
APPEARS TO PUT IT OF EXISTING
EFFORTS BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS A BASED ON A SIMILAR
PROPOSAL CONSIDERED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY BUDGET
BUDGET PROCESS THE DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH REQUIRE TWO
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR
THE GENERAL FUND A SUBJECT AN
APPROPRIATION ADDITIONALLY THIS
BILL REQUIRES COORDINATION AMONG
US SEVERAL STATE AGENCIES WHICH
COULD ADDITION TO CREATE A COST
PRESSURES WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SIX FIVE SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVIE ON THE A. B. TEN
TEN HOUSING PROGRAMS IS THERE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
COSTS OF THREE HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN THE FIRST
YEAR AND TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS ON GOING
GENERAL FUND -- RELATED TO THIS
BILL THAT OBJECTION A. B.
TEN TEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT MISTER
ARAMBULA ON WATER RIGHTS SIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
THIS WOULD OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE UNLESS AMENDED TO
AUTHORIZE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE TO ASSESS THE
FEE TO RECOVER ITS COSTS FROM
PUBLIC AGENCIES THAT APPLY FOR
PERMITS THE DEPARTMENT OF A
FISSION LIVE LIKE WILDLIFE
ESTIMATES THE WILL REQUIRE SIX
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE GENERAL FUND IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY INCREASING TO
ONE POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIX
FIVE EIGHT WE'LL GO TO
SUSPENSE TURNING TO PAGE SIX
MR LEVINE STARTING WITH AB
SIX EIGHTY FOUR THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE THIS WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURES WILL
LIKELY RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
STATE COSTS WHILE THEY'RE
ALREADY ADMINISTRATIVE EFFORTS
UNDER WAY TO INSTALL CHARGING
STATIONS FOR EXISTING BUILDINGS
THE DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
COSTS OF ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY ONE AND ONE
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
COSTS OF AT LEAST TWO HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS IN
TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWO
HUNDRED ELEVEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO AND MINOR IN OBSERVABLE
COSTS ON GOING THAT OBJECTION
AB SIX EIGHTY FOUR WATER
SUSPENSE AB ELEVEN THIRTY
PERSONAL INFORMATION SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE THIS PROPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
PLACE IS UNKNOWN AND BUDGETED
COSTS UPON THE STATE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE ESTIMATES OF COST
TO THE UNFAIR COMPETITION
LAW FUNDED TWO HUNDRED EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND THREE
HUNDRED FIFTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND ANNUALLY THEREAFTER
THAT OBJECTION AB ELEVEN
THIRTY WITHOUT A SUSPENSE A. B.
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX PUBLIC WORKS
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE WE'RE
NEUTRAL ON THIS BILL BECAUSE
THE INCREASED COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH IT CAN BE SUSTAINED THROUGH
A MINOR FEE INCREASE BUT WE
DO KNOW CONCERNED THAT THE
BILL WILL RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
COSTS ON INCLUDING THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT THE BOARD
-- WITHIN THE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FORESTRY AND FIRE PROTECTION
INDICATES THE BILL WILL RESULT
IN COST OF A HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM
THE SAFE ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE
AN EXCAVATION FUND TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY AND ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS ON
GOING WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB ELEVEN SIXTY SIX WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB FIFTEEN EIGHTY
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE THIS
WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT IS DUPLICATIVE OF
EXISTING EFFORTS THE DEPARTMENT
OF GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES
COSTS OF UP TO FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR FROM
THE SERVICE REVOLVING FUND
THAT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
EIGHTY WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN ON BEACHES
THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
AND RECREATION ESTIMATES IT
WILL OCCUR ADDITIONAL ONE
TIME COST OF A PULL UP TO ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION DOLLARS
TO PAY FOR THE PURCHASE AND
INSTALLATION OF SIGNAGE NOTICING
THE PROHIBITS PROVISIONS IN
THE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY UNITS
OF THE STATE PARK SYSTEM AND
TO THE EXTENT THAT NEW FUNDING
IS UNAVAILABLE TO FUND THE
OBLIGATION CREATED BY THIS BILL
RESOURCES WILL BE RE DIRECTED
FOR MAINTENANCE PROJECTS AND
NATURAL AND CULTURAL MANAGEMENT
EFFORTS THAT OBJECTION
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WE'LL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB SEVEN
A ONE WEBER ON EXONERATION
HOUSING COSTS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
WE'RE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BECAUSE IT RESULTS
IN SIGNIFICANT COSTS TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION NOT INCLUDED IN
THE ADMINISTRATION'S CURRENT
FISCAL PLAN MOREOVER RENO THAT
EXONERATED VISUAL IS ALREADY
ENTITLED TO COMPENSATION
UPON RELEASE THAT OBJECTION
AB SEVEN A ONE -- WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB NINE FORTY TWO
CAL FOR US SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE
THE RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT
GENERAL FUND COSTS NOT CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S FISCAL
PLAN OF THIS BILL RESULTS IN
COSTS OF APPROXIMATELY FIVE
HUNDRED THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SEVEN
THOUSAND OF WHICH IS GENERAL
FUND IN TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND POTENTIALLY UP TO ONE
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS I
HAVE WHICH IS GENERAL FUND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO SUPPORT
A NEW POSITIONS WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB NINE FOUR
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN A CALL
CENTER SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE GUESTS WERE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULT
IN UNKNOWN BUT SIGNIFICANT
COSTS TO THE STATE TO COMPLY
WITH THE REQUIREMENT THAT ALL
STATE AGENCIES WITH CONTRACT
WITH CALL CENTERS TO PERFORM
THEIR SERVICES WITHIN THE STATE
AS WELL AS ADMINISTRATIVE COST
IMPLEMENT THE BILL THAT ARE
NOT CONSISTENT WITH THE CURRENT
BUDGET THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS ESTIMATES
COSTS OF ONE POINT THREE MILLION
DOLLARS INITIALLY AND SIX
HUNDRED TWENTY THREE THOUSAND
DOLLARS ON GOING FOR THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
FUND ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE MOVING TO MISTER
NAZARIAN STARTING WITH
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTEEN ANSWER
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
THIS PROPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT CREATES GENERAL FUND
COST PRESSURES TO CONTINUE THE
PROGRAM THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
BUDGET INCLUDED THREE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND OVER THREE YEARS FOR
THIS IS FOR THIS PROGRAM
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH EXPECTS ALL FUNDS
TO BE ENCUMBERED BY THE END
OF TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
DOES NOT INCLUDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR THIS PROGRAM
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
FIFTEEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB
TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN NO WRONG
DOOR SYSTEM THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE DEPARTMENT
OF AGING ESTIMATES GENERAL
FUND COST BETWEEN SEVENTY
SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS TO THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
ASSOCIATED WITH THIS BILL A
ANY COST TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF REHABILITATION THE
DEPARTMENT SOCIAL SERVICES
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ARE ESTIMATED
TO BE MINOR ADDITIONALLY THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCIES WILL INCUR
COSTS LIKELY IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND TO CONSULT WITH THE VARIOUS
DEPARTMENTS LASTLY THIS BILL
CREATES A SUBSTANTIAL FEATURE
GENERAL FUND COST PRESSURE TO
IMPLEMENT THE SYSTEM STATEWIDE
-- AND UNIVERSAL ASSESSMENT TOOL
THAT REJECT WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWELVE EIGHTY SEVEN
WILL GO TO HIS FRIENDS
THE MAN AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
-- INVESTMENT DIVESTITURE
IS THERE SUPPORT OF OPPOSITION
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHOICE ONE MARTINEZ WEIGHT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
TEACHERS RETIREMENT SYSTEM
IN OPPOSITION THERE FINANCE
REPORT YES ACCORDING TO CALPERS
THEY WILL INCUR POTENTIAL
TRADE COSTS TO COMPLY WITH
THIS BILL THAT COULD EXTEND
INTO THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ADDITIONALLY CASTERS ESTIMATES
-- ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN INITIAL TRANSACTION COSTS
TO COMPLY WITH THE BILL WITH
ON GOING COST OF FORTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS AS OF JANUARY
THIRTY FIRST TWENTY NINETEEN
CASTERS ESTIMATES HOLDINGS
OF DEBT SECURITIES ISSUED BY
THE TURKISH GOVERNMENT TO BE
APPROXIMATELY THREE POINT TWO
MILLION DOLLARS AND ESTIMATES
THE MARKET VALUE OF GLOBAL
EQUITIES IN CURRENT CURRENCY
INVESTMENT SUBJECT POSSIBLE
DIVESTMENT TO BE UP TO EIGHT
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS
THAT OBJECTION A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY WILL GO TWO SUSPECTS
MOVING ON A MYSTERY O'DONNELL
STARTING WITH A V. SEVEN
FIVE ONE PATHWAY TO COLLEGE
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS ALLOWING LOCAL EDUCATIONAL
AGENCIES TO ADMINISTER THE
ASSESSMENT AND ASSESSMENT OTHER
THAN THE CAST CREATES DESPERATE
MEASURES OF STUDENT ACADEMIC
ACHIEVEMENT ACROSS THE STATE
THIS TO ME THIS BILL CREATES ONE
TIME COST OF APPROXIMATELY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS NOT PROPOSITION
NINETY GENERAL FUND OVER FOUR
YEARS ADDITIONALLY WE FOR
THEIR ESTIMATE THE BILL CREATES
ON GOING PROPOSITION NINETY
GENERAL FUND COSTS IN THE MID
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
FOR ASSESSMENT CONTRACTORS TO
CONDUCT STUDIES AND PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE MONITORING AS
PART OF THE REVIEW PROCESS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SEVEN
FIFTY ONE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SIX WHILE
REVENUE OIL TRUST FUNDS
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THE RESULTS IN A GENERAL
FUND REVENUE REDUCTION OF
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY INCLUDING
SURPLUS MONEY INVESTMENT FUND
INTEREST EARNINGS THIS IS THE
RESULT OF THE REDUCTION OF
FUNDS THAT OTHERWISE WOULD
BE DEPOSITED INTO THE GENERAL
FUND TO THE OIL TRUST FUND
ACTION A. B. NINE TWENTY SIX
WILL GO TO SUSPENSE AB TEN
NINETY EIGHT ON SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDERS SUPPORT
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS TELLING
MEASURE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL DRUG PROGRAM EXECUTIVES
WE THINK THIS IS WELL WORTH THE
INVESTMENT TO PROVIDE GUIDANCE
FOR FUTURE FOR FUTURE ALLOCATION
OF FUNDS THANK YOU FINANCE
IS WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS IT LIMITS THE AUTHORITY
OF PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
GRANTED TO THE ADMINISTRATION
TO SET PRIORITIES FOR FUNDS
ALLOCATED TO VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL RESULT
IN ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS
POTENTIALLY IN THE MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS TO IMPLEMENT ITS
PROVISIONS THAT OBJECTION
AB TEN NINETY EIGHT WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB FORTINO SIX
ALTERNATIVE WRITTEN RENEWABLE
FUELS THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE BY SETTING ASIDE FUNDING
FOR SPECIFIED PURPOSES THIS
BILL LIMITS THE COMMISSION'S
ABILITY TO RESPOND TO MARKET AND
TECHNOLOGY CONDITIONS AND EVENTS
FOR MOST COST EFFECTIVE PROJECTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FORTINO
SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE A.
B. SIXTEEN THIRTEEN PUBLIC
WORKS PREVAILING WAGE THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS ESTIMATES COST OF
A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS FROM THE LABOR
ENFORCEMENT AND COMPLIANCE
FUND INITIALLY AND ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING ADDITIONALLY THE
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL FINANCE
AUTHORITY -- ESTIMATES THIS
BILL WILL INCREASE CONSTRUCTION
COSTS BY AN UNKNOWN AMOUNT
FOR CHARTER SCHOOL PROJECTS
THAT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO THE
PREVAILING WAGE REQUIREMENTS
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN
THIRTEEN WOULD GO TO SUSPENSE
AB SIXTEEN NINETY FOUR DIMMING
THIS CHANNEL WATERSHED SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE WE OPPOSE
THIS MEASURE AS A CREATES
UNKNOWN FUTURE COST PRESSURES
AND BECAUSE THE CONSERVANCY'S
BUDGET DOES NOT INCLUDE
RESOURCES TO IMPLEMENT PROJECTS
IN THE TERRITORIES ADDED TO
THE CONSERVANCY'S JURISDICTION
ADDITIONALLY THERE'S ALREADY
A NONPROFIT WITH JURISDICTION
OVER SANTA CAN AT SANTA CATALINA
ISLAND THE CATALINA CONSERVANCY
IS CURRENTLY RESPONSIBLE FOR
CONSERVATION OF EIGHTY PERCENT
OF SANTA KALACH CANTELLI
CATALINA ISLAND WITHOUT
OBJECTION AB SIXTEEN NINETY
FOUR WITHOUT A SUSPENSE MISTER
BIGELOW AS ONE BILL AB SEVEN
FIFTY NINE ON TRAFFIC SAFETY
SUPPORT SPORT TENNIS LOWER
PER INCH FOR PACIFIC HIGHWAY
RENTALS IN TRAFFIC MANAGEMENT
IN SUPPORT WE NOTE THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SHOWS SOME
EIGHTY MILLION AND AND LOSSES
TO CALTRANS ANNUAL IN TORTS AND
TRAGICALLY A NUMBER OF CALTRANS
TO US OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS
THAT DOESN'T EVEN APPROACH OUR
ACCOUNT FOR PUBLIC TILSON AND
TORCH ALSO WE THINK TO THIS BILL
WOULD SAVE MANY OF THOSE THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR ANY OPPOSITION
FINANCE IS WHERE NEUTRON THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT CAN COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO REDUCING THE RISK
FOR EMPLOYEES OF CALTRANS OUR
CONTRACTORS AT ROAD CONSTRUCTION
AND MAINTENANCE SITES WE KNOW
CONCERNED THAT INCREASING THE
COST OF PROJECTS WILL REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF PROJECTS THAT
CALTRANS IS ABLE TO COMPLETE
EACH YEAR -- AND WILL ULTIMATELY
IMPACT THEIR ABILITY TO MEET
ITS STATUTORY ROAD MAINTENANCE
TARGETS THAT OBJECTION AB
SEVEN FIFTY NINE WITH A
SUSPENSE MOVING TIM MS BAUER
CAHAN AB EIGHT OH SEVEN ON
CAL WORKS SEARCH SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WERE
POSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE
THEY COULD POTENTIALLY RESULT
IN SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL
FUND COSTS NOT CURRENTLY
INCLUDED IN THE STATE'S
FISCAL PLAN ADDITIONALLY THE
EXEMPTION OF CERTAIN FUNDS FROM
BEING CONSIDERED AS INCOME IS
DUPLICATIVE OF EXISTING EFFORTS
MADE BY THE ADMINISTRATION THIS
BILL WILL RESULT IN UNKNOWN
GENERAL FUND COSTS LIKELY IN
THE LOW MILLIONS TO TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THAT IS JACKSON AVIATOR SEVEN
WITHOUT A SUSPENSE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY FOR PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
ACT -- THEIR SUPPORT
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLUTION
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION AND
STRONG SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE'RE NEUTRAL
ON THIS MEASURE OF BUT
YOU HAVE CONCERNS THAT THE
ADDITIONAL COSTS RESULTING
FROM THIS BILL MAY REQUIRE
AN INCREASE IN REGISTRATION
FEES MOVING TO MS WICKS
AB EIGHT THREE SIX ON WILDFIRE
SMOKE CLEANER CENTERS SUPPORT
ALLEN ABS WITH THE BAY AREA
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT
-- ALSO SPONSOR THE BILL IN
SUPPORT OF -- -- THIS PROGRAM
WHICH WOULD ADDRESS A GAP IN
THE CURRENT STATEWIDE PUBLIC
HEALTH -- RESPONSE TO WILDFIRES
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION
ROSSBACH INFO SOUTH COAST
AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT SORRY
OPPOSITION SING NINE FINANCE
YES WE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
BECAUSE IT CREATES UNKNOWN
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT COST
PRESSURES TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROGRAM AND PROVIDE THE FUNDING
INCENTIVES A YEAR RESOURCES
BOARD ESTIMATES COSTS OF FIVE
HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS
FROM THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
FUND A AND THREE POSITIONS
ON GOING TO DEVELOP PROGRAM
GUIDELINES ONLY WE KNOW THAT
THE PROGRAM IS CONTINGENT
UPON AN APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE BUT THE BILL DOES
NOT IDENTIFY FUNDS SOURCE
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB EIGHT THREE
SIX FOUR ZERO TWO SUSPECTS AB
TWELVE TWENTY NINE FOSTER YOUTH
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE IS
WERE OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE
AS IT WOULD RESULT IN UNKNOWN
GENERAL FUND COSTS ARE LIKELY
IN THE HIGH TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY THAT OBJECTION
AB TWELVE TWENTY NINE GO TO
SUSPECTS A. B. SIXTEEN OH THREE
OF VIOLENCE INTERVENTION SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE OF WHAT
THE BILL DOES NOT INCLUDE
AN APPROPRIATION TO SUPPORT
THE PROGRAM BY CODIFYING THE
PROGRAM IN THE PENAL CODE IT
WOULD CREATE -- CHEN OFTEN
COST PRESSURES TO FUNDED IN THE
FUTURE I WOULD KNOW THAT THE
BUDGET ACT OF TWENTY NINETEEN
APPROPRIATED THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND FOR THIS
PROGRAM NINE MILLION OF WHICH IS
ONGOING -- AND WHILE THE BUDGET
ACT REQUIRES GRANT RECIPIENTS
TO MATCH THE GRANT FULLER
THIS BILL ALLOWS THE BOARD OF
STATE COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS
TO WAIVE THAT MATCH FOR THAT
BECAUSE WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB SIXTY NO THREE WILL GO TO
SUSPENSE AB EIGHT SIXTY ONE
BY MISTER CHAN ON JUVENILES
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
TO EXTEND THIS BILL INCREASES
ADMINISTRATIVE WORKLOAD FOR
COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS TO
COMPLY WITH ITS PROVISIONS
THIS BILL WILL END RESULT IN
INCREASED GENERAL FUND COSTS
A WE ESTIMATE THE BILL COULD
RESULT IN COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS TO
THE LOW MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY -- ANY COST TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES OR
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL RESULTING
FROM THIS BILL ARE ESTIMATED
TO BE MINOR AND OBSERVABLE
OUT OBJECTION A. B. C. EIGHT
SIX ONE WILL GO THE SUSPENSE
MISTER RODRIGUEZ HAS ONE
BILL AB NINE ELEVEN ON
EMERGENCY SERVICES THEIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE
THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES
ESTIMATES THE COST OF THIS
BILL WOULD BE BETWEEN TEN POINT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS AND SIXTY
POINT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM
THE STATE EMERGENCY TELEPHONE
NETWORK ACCOUNT ANNUALLY
BEGINNING IN FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB NINE
ELEVEN WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO -- ROBERT RIVAS
-- AB NINE THREE SIX OIL SPILLS
SUPPORT IS THE CHAIR
JUST MOVE ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT WE WILL
-- SAUCE BY THE SIERRA CLUB
IN THE LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION
TO SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
CARE TO SO ON BEHALF OF HEAL
THE BAY IN SUPPORT I'VE ALSO
BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER SUPPORT
FOR THE SURFRIDER FOUNDATION
THANK YOU VERY OPPOSITION SERRA
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE
BILL WOULD EXACERBATE THE
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND THE OIL
SPILL PREVENTION ADMINISTRATION
FUND THE OFFICE CANNOT ABSORB
THE COST OF THE NEW AND
EXPANDED MANDATES IN THIS
BILL ADDITIONALLY DEPARTMENT
OFFICIAL WILDLIFE IS UNDERGOING
AN INDEPENDENT SERVICE BASED
BUDGET REVIEW AND ABILITY A
TRACKING SYSTEM TO SUPPORT AN
ANALYSIS OF THE DEPARTMENT'S
EXISTING REVENUE AND STRUCTURE
OF PROGRAM ACTIVITIES WE BELIEVE
IT IS PREMATURE TO ADD OR MODIFY
ANY PROGRAMMATIC REQUIREMENTS
-- BEFORE THIS VIEW HIS
COMPLETE WITHOUT OBJECTION
A. B. NINE THIRTY SIX WILL
GO TWO SUSPECTS AB TWELVE
FIFTY FIVE SURPLUS PUBLIC LAND
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES
BECAUSE OF FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND IN THE FIRST YEAR AND FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON GOING
ADDITIONALLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
GENERAL SERVICES ESTIMATES COSTS
OF SIX HUNDRED TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN ONE TIME GENERAL FUND
A AND NINE HUNDRED EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON
GOING FOR RESOURCES ASSOCIATED
WITH THIS BILL WITHOUT OBJECTION
AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE OTHER
SUSPECTS EIGHTY NINE SIXTY TWO
-- IS BURKE ON HOSPITALS THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
THE OFFICE OF THE OFFICE OF
STATEWIDE HEALTH PLANNING AND
DEVELOPMENT ESTIMATES COST OF
SEVEN HUNDRED NINETY THOUSAND
DOLLARS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
HEALTH DATA AND PLANNING
FUNDING TWENTY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE AND TWO HUNDRED SIXTY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER WITHOUT
OBJECTION A. B. NINE SIXTY
TWO WILL GO TO SUSPENSE OF THE
NUMBERS TO CALL THEIR OWN AB
NINE SEVENTY FIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THE NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY ESTIMATES COST OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
ON GOING FROM THE GENERAL FUND
ADDITIONALLY THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING AND RESEARCH
ESTIMATES -- COSTS OF A ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND ON GOING WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE THE RESULT
IN ONGOING COSTS -- NOT INCLUDED
IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET
ACT THAT OBJECTION
AB NINE SEVEN FIVE -- WILL GO TO
SUSPEND SAY BE FIFTEEN SEVENTY
SIX ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE
THAT'S THE THIRD ONE WE'VE HAD
TODAY IF SOMEONE SENDING US A
MESSAGE THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WERE OPPOSED TO THIS
BILL BECAUSE THE RESULTS AND
ON BUDGET GENERAL FUND COSTS OF
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO THE GOVERNMENT
OPERATIONS AGENCY A DUPLICATE IT
DUPLICATES AN EXISTING STATEWIDE
EFFORT AND WOULD PROVIDE
INFORMATION IN A LESS TIMELY
FASHION THAN THE EXISTING EFFORT
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB FIFTEEN
SEVENTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MOVING ON TO A BE SIXTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT ON REHABILITATION
PROGRAMS RECIDIVISM SIR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE WE ARE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURES THE
DUPLICATES EXISTING PROGRAM
EVALUATION AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAM IMPROVEMENT EFFORTS
UNDERWAY AT SIGNIFICANT COST
TO THE STATE OF CORRECTIONS
AND REHABILITATION ESTIMATES
SIGNIFICANT COSTS -- IN
THE MILLIONS OF DOLLARS TO
IMPLEMENT THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL AS A CURRENTLY HAS
EIGHTY THREE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS ACROSS THIRTY FIVE
INSTITUTIONS WHICH COULD MERIT
STUDY UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS MEASURE THAT OBJECTION
AB SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT WILL
GO THE SUSPENSE MR MCCARTY HAS
THREE BILLS TIME WITH AB ONE
THOUSAND FOR A DEVELOPMENTAL
SCREENING SERVICES SUPPORT
THREE NEVER GONNA ON BEHALF
OF FIRST BY BILLION PERCENT
ASSOCIATION CO SPONSORS OF
THIS MEASURE AND ON BEHALF OF
FOR SAFE CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS BILL CLARIFIES --
AN EXISTING MANDATE ALREADY IN
PLACE THEREFORE WE BELIEVE THAT
THE MINOR FISCAL COST IDENTIFY
BUT THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
-- FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THIS BILL SHOULD ALREADY
BE OF ABSORBED BY THE EQ RO
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES WE ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AS IT IS
DUPLICATIVE OF RECENT ACTIONS
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES AND INVESTMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT OF THE DEPARTMENT
-- ESTIMATES ANNUAL COST OF
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS
OF WHICH IS GENERAL FUND OVER
THREE YEARS THAT OBJECTION
AB ONE THOUSAND FOUR WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE
ON SUBSTANCE USE PREVENTION
SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WE MAKE CHARM HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES IN OPPOSITION --
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A
PREMATURE BILL AND -- THE ANY
ANY ALLOCATION OF FUNDS SHOULD
WAIT UNTIL THERE IS A PROPER
ASSESSMENT NUMBER ABOUT STUDY
OF WHAT THE NEEDS ARE THANK YOU
PILOTS YES WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS MEASURE AS THE INITIATIVE
PERHAPS THE LEGISLATURE
FROM MAKING CHANGES TO THE
ALLEGATIONS TO PROPOSITION
SIXTY FOUR PROGRAMS PURGE JULY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT OF
THE INITIAL LIKE WAYS GAVE
DEPARTMENTS AT THAT RISKY
PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR FUNDING
AUTONOMY ON HOW TO USE THOSE
FUNDS THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH
CARE SERVICES HAS ALREADY
IDENTIFIED USES FOR THESE FUNDS
FOR THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
FISCAL YEAR AND ON GOING AND
AS A RESULT THIS BILL CREATES
ON GOING COSTS IN THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS NOT
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL
FUND FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO IMPLEMENT THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB
TEN EIGHTY FIVE WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE --
ACR SIXTY FOUR IS NEXT DOOR
IS THERE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE FILE THAT OBJECTION ACR
SIXTY FOUR WHEELERS SUSPENSE
MR OBERNOLTE HAS ONE BILL AB
TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE IS WERE
OPPOSED TO THIS MEASURE AS THE
ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH IT RESULTS IN GENERAL
FUND COSTS TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF HEALTH CARE SERVICES
APPROXIMATELY SEVEN HUNDRED
SEVENTY ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY AND
ONE POINT TWO MILLION DOLLARS
AND KNOW THAT THEY'RE AFTER
ADDITIONALLY THE PROVISIONS
OF THIS BILL APPEARED TO
BE PARTIALLY DUPLICATIVE
OF EXISTING EFFORTS THAT
OBJECTION AB TWELVE TWENTY
SEVEN WILL GO THE SUSPENSE
MS SMITH HAS AB TWELVE THIRTY
THREE THEIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FILE WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE AS IT THE BILL CREATES
COST PRESSURES OF UP TO TWENTY
POINT ONE MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GENERAL FUND ANNUALLY FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY THROUGH
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR FOR GRANTS TO SUBSIDIZE
ADVANCED PLACEMENT EXAMINATIONS
-- WITHOUT OBJECTION AB TWELVE
THIRTY THREE WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
MAYES RUBIO HAS TWO BILLS
OUR LAST FOUR -- AB THIRTEEN
OH SEVEN ON CAL GRANTS
SIR SUPPORT OPPOSITION FINANCE
TO THIS MEASURES A CREATE
SIGNIFICANT ONGOING GENERAL FUND
COSTS IN THE TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT ARE NOT ACCOUNTED
FOR IN THE STATE'S MULTI YEAR
BUDGET FORECAST ADDITIONALLY
THIS BILL UNDERMINES ONGOING
EFFORTS TO INCREASE THE PATHWAYS
FOR STUDENTS TRANSFER FROM
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO THE
FOUR YEAR INSTITUTIONS USING
CONSISTENT ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER PROCESS BUT OBJECTION
AB THIRTEEN OH SEVEN WILL GO
TO CSUS FENCE AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN -- CANNABIS SUPPORT
OPPOSITION FINANCE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS ESTIMATES
THE BEER OF CANNABIS CONTROL
WOULD EXPERIENCE A SLIGHT
INCREASE IN A FOR SPENT WORKLOAD
RELATED TO THE ADVERTISING AND
MARKETING PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL THE PROVISIONS OF WHICH
WE OF PLEA TO BE ABSORBED
WITHIN EXISTING RESOURCES
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
ESTIMATES IT IS DIFFICULT
TO DETERMINE THE INCREASE
IN WORKLOAD FROM THIS BILL
-- TO THE EXTENT ANY CASES
ARE REFERRED TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL THIS BILL WOULD INCREASE
WORKLOAD AND COSTS BUT WOULD
BE THOSE COSTS WOULD BE DIRECT
BILLED TO THE STATE AGENCY
THAT REFER THE CASE DEPENDING
ON THE CASE OF THOSE COSTS
WOULD BE DIRECTLY OR INDIRECTLY
OFFSET BY CIVIL PUNISH THE
PENALTIES FROM THIS MEASURE
THAT OBJECTION AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN WILL GO TWO SUSPECTS
MR HOLDEN AS ONE BILL AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ON OIL
AND GAS STUDY OF ABANDONED
WELLS SCISSORS PORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE YES FOR NEUTRONS
MEASURE THAT OBJECTION AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WILL GO
TO SUSPENSE AND OUR FINAL BILL
IS A. B. THIRTEEN SEVENTY SIX BY
MISTER RAMOS ON VETERANS THEIR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION
FINANCE THIS ROOM OPPOSED
TO THIS MEASURE AS THERE IS
ALREADY A BACKGROUND CHECK
PROCESS IN PLACE THAT IS NOT
BURDENSOME TO VETERANS WERE
SEEKING CYBERSECURITY JOBS
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
HUMAN RESOURCES AND IT'S THE
BILL WOULD INCREASE COSTS
ALTHOUGH THE EXTENT OF THOSE
COSTS ARE UNKNOWN AT THIS TIME
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS ESTIMATES AND
COSTS RELATED TO THIS BILL ARE
MINOR AN OBSERVABLE -- HOWEVER
IS THE DEPARTMENT IS REQUIRED TO
EVALUATE THE SECURITY CLEARANCES
ACOSTA THE DEPARTMENT COULD BE
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
WITHOUT OBJECTION AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SIX WILL GO TO SUSPENSE
AND THAT CONCLUDES OUR BUSINESS
WITHIN MISS ANYTHING SOME WILL
BE BACK WILL BE BACK HERE NEXT
MONDAY TWICE AS MANY BELLS
CRISIS LONG EVERYBODY HAVE
A GOOD WEEK GENERATING LOTS OF
PAPER THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED
THANK EVERYBODY AND WELCOME BACK